[Music]
welcome to the huberman lab guest Series
where I and an expert guest discuss
science and science-based tools for
everyday life
I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and Ophthalmology at
Stanford school of medicine today marks
the third episode in our four episode
series about mental health with Dr Paul
Conte today's episode deals with the
topic of healthy relationships how to
define what a healthy relationship is
and how to achieve healthy relationships
of all kinds including romantic
relationships interpersonal
relationships at work friendships with
family and of course with oneself this
episode Builds on the framework of the
psychology of self and mental health
that was established in the first and
second episodes of this series however
even if you didn't listen to the first
or second episode in this series today's
episode will still contain a lot of
information and protocols that you will
find valuable for improving your
relationships that said if you have the
opportunity to listen to the first and
second episodes in this series I think
you'll find those to be tremendously
beneficial at any point during today's
episode Dr Conte discusses what makes
for a successful relationship of any
kind as well as tools to improve those
relationships he discusses various types
of bonds including healthy bonds and
Trauma bonds not just in the context of
romantic relationship but in the context
of all types of relationships we also
discussed different challenges that
people face in relationships including
abusive relationships and we discuss the
role of power dynamics anxiety and
boundaries in relationships both from
the perspective of unhealthy
relationships but more importantly from
the understanding and protocols to
cultivate healthy relationships while
there is an abundance of opinions and
information out there on the internet
these days about relationships both
healthy and unhealthy today's discussion
approaches the topic of relationships
through an entirely different lens which
is the lens of the self in terms of
one's conscious and subconscious mind
and how multiple conscious and
subconscious Minds through different
individuals interact with one another in
ways that we can see and ways that we
can't see and all of that framed within
the actionable steps that any of us can
take to improve our relationship to
ourself and to others before we begin
I'd like to emphasize that this podcast
is separate from my teaching and
research roles at Stanford it is however
part of my desire and effort to bring
zero cost to Consumer information about
science and science related tools to the
general public in keeping with that
theme I'd like to thank the sponsors of
today's podcast our first sponsor is
betterhelp betterhelp offers
Professional Therapy with a licensed
therapist carried out all online I've
been doing therapy for more than 30
years while I confess that initially I
was forced to do that therapy as a
condition for being let back into high
school over time I learned that therapy
is a tremendously valuable practice in
fact I consider doing regular weekly
therapy as just as important as doing
regular physical exercise in order to
improve one's Health the beauty of
better help is that it makes it
extremely easy to find a therapist
that's excellent for you and we can
define an excellent therapist as
somebody who's going to give you a lot
of support but in an objective way as
well as somebody with whom you can have
excellent Rapport and that can help you
arrive at positively transformative
insights that you wouldn't have
otherwise had and with better help they
make it convenient so that it's matched
to your schedule and the other aspects
of your life if you'd like to try better
help go to betterhelp.com huberman to
get 10 off your first month again that's
betterhelp help help.com huberman
today's episode is also brought To Us by
waking up waking up is a meditation app
that offers dozens of guided meditation
sessions mindfulness trainings yoga
needs recessions and more
by now there's an abundance of data
showing that even short daily
meditations can greatly improve our mood
reduce anxiety improve our ability to
focus and can improve our memory and
while there are many different forms of
meditation most people find it difficult
to find and stick to a meditation
practice in a way that is most
beneficial for them the waking up app
makes it extremely easy to learn how to
meditate and to carry out your daily
meditation practice in a way that's
going to be most effective and efficient
for you it includes a variety of
different types of meditations of
different duration as well as things
like Yoga Nidra which place the brain
and body into a sort of pseudo sleep
that allows you to emerge feeling
incredibly mentally refreshed in fact
the science around Yoga Nidra is really
impressive showing that after a Yoga
Nidra session levels of dopamine in
certain areas of the brain are enhanced
by up to 60 percent which places the
brain and body into a state of enhanced
Readiness for mental work and for
physical work another thing I really
like about the waking up app is that it
provides a 30 day introduction course so
for those of you that have not meditated
before or getting back to a meditation
practice that's fantastic or if you're
somebody who's already a skilled and
regular meditator waking up has more
advanced meditations and yoga need your
sessions for you as well if you'd like
to try the waking up app you can go to
wakingup.com huberman and access a free
30-day trial again that's wakingup.com
huberman and now for my discussion about
mental health with Dr Paul Conti Dr
Conti welcome back thank you happy to be
here
today we're going to discuss
relationships and that will often focus
on romantic relationships but also
relationships between friends between
family members and inevitably the
relationship to self which is what we
really focused on in episodes one and
two of this series episode one being all
the things that go into a healthy self
and how to understand what is unhealthy
and healthy in all of us and make
adjustments to the unhealthy aspects of
our unconscious and conscious through
really specific proactive
behaviors and patterns of thought so
really a road map to these ideals that
we call mental health and understanding
of the self
today we want to talk about
relationships from the perspective of of
course how people relate but I have a
feeling it's going to have something to
do with or perhaps almost everything to
do with our relationship to
understanding ourselves first yes so
just to make sure that we're all on the
same page regardless of whether or not
people have seen episodes one and two
and certainly people do not need to have
seen or listened to episodes one and two
of the series in order to understand
today's discussion
could you please tell us
what is a healthy person and how can we
ask ourselves the sorts of questions
that allow us to determine whether or
not we are healthy and where to look in
terms of making adjustments if we want
to be healthier than we already are
which I have to believe almost everybody
if not everybody certainly wants to be
the healthiest and best expression of
themselves so that they can do the most
for themselves and for others in the
world so the the linchpin of it all
right is the agency and gratitude as
verbs right that's the top of the
mountain right there's a lot of climbing
we do to get to the top of the mountain
once we're over the top of the mountain
then things are in a better place and
even though they're two words right
agency is of course a word gratitude is
a word but it doesn't mean that there
are separate Concepts approaching the
world through the lens of agency and
gratitude thought of as one thing
because they come together and they come
together as verbs like that's what we're
aiming for right because that's the
thing that we can work towards right if
you think about what comes underneath of
that right it takes us back to the the
two pillars and the the ten cupboards
right and if we're looking in there
enough we're mining like what is in my
unconscious mind I might not be aware of
let me generate some curiosity about my
defense mechanisms and my character
structure and think about what Salient
inside of me like if we're doing doing
all of that then what we're doing we're
building empowerment we're building
humility and then ultimately the
expression of all of that is the agency
and gratitude and it's something that we
can't have enough of like I said what's
the best amount of that the most that's
possible right because we're going to
engage in the world in the healthiest
way because agency and gratitude doesn't
mean like we're happy about everything
right if there's something negative
and we can change that then we don't
feel happy about that we we the sense of
gratitude in me makes me more likely to
feel that I can change that right or to
take the chance of trying to change that
and then the agency part of that concept
can come more to the fore and I can make
the change so it's not about Bliss right
it's not about forgiving self and others
for all sorts of things and not working
to make better it's about being in the
world and being as aware as I can
possibly be including being aware that
there are things I'm not aware of right
so sort of having a healthy respect and
an orientation to the world that values
truth and values understanding and
exploration if we do all of that then we
reach the top of the mountain through
the agency and gratitude and then what
builds upon that or what comes from that
is the the peace the contentment the
Delight the generative Drive being
strengthened like that all comes
together and then the aggressive or we
say aggressive because that's the
traditional term with the aggressive or
the assertive right the assertiveness
recertion Drive however we what whatever
word we want to put to that that drive
exists in us in a way that subserves the
generative Drive the same thing with the
pleasure Drive in US it exists in us but
it's observing the generative drive and
then all those good things come together
and they come together to help us be as
healthy as we can and to stay healthy
right including when tribulation or
difficulties come our way so that we
stay as best we can in the agency and
gratitude as verbs and again there's
nothing
theoretical about this like it's a way
to live and and there are a lot of
people who live some of their lives or
parts of their lives through that right
and we can aspire to it and we can work
towards it and if we're the best that we
can be then we're going to be in our
relationships the best we can be like
think about it like you and I have a
relationship we know each other we're
working together if I can bring my best
self to you to thinking about you to
understanding you if I can bring the
agency and the Gratitude then I'm going
to do right by you I'm going to
mentalize this idea of thinking about
what's going on inside of you like I'm
going to bring the best of all of that
and then because we have a relationship
there's also in us like there's a me
there's a you there's something that
happens between us that's the
relationship that's the US and I will
also bring my best self to that thing
that is no longer just me or just you
but that isn't us and that applies to
all relationships right you can apply
that to see Health in every single
relationship in our lives
what you're saying really speaks to the
importance of people taking a real look
at themselves you know which is not
necessarily an inventory of Self in the
typical sense that we're used to hearing
it but rather through this lens or map
of the self that was spelled out in
episodes one and two and again for those
that are just joining the series now
um the map as we're referring to it is
available as a downloadable PDF in the
show note captions if people want to get
that it's completely zero cost you can
just go there and access it or just view
it on a screen print it out whatever
whatever you like
you certainly don't need to do that
because here again we're talking about
the core elements of that map which
I understand correctly
arrive eventually at a set of verb
states that we're calling agency and
gratitude those are not separate as you
pointed out they work together
you described as a on top of the geyser
right and I I really like that like
there's a lot of things going on but
then it all uplifts to something right
and if we're doing it in the right way
in the in the diligent way then it is
like a geyser and what it's lifting up
on top of it is the agency and gratitude
I I love you you put those words to it
and I think it captures it really
profoundly
well the the stuff that geysers up
perhaps deserves a bit of our attention
um just for a few moments
um you describe these two pillars that
I described as geysering up into agency
and gratitude in the in the best
circumstances but
the best circumstances we want to remind
ourselves and everybody are attainable
by looking at what's in those pillars
those two pillars are the structure of
self so really understanding something
about the structure of self so that
includes some understanding of the
unconscious mind some understanding of
the conscious mind defense mechanisms
character structure and self that was
all reviewed and described in episodes
one and two
as well as the functions of self which
are more of the verb States the
expressions of the structure of self
-awareness in the first of those defense
mechanisms in action and here
um I'd be remiss if I didn't
tell myself and everybody else again
that defense mechanisms are not always
bad there can be healthy defense
mechanisms absolutely they can protect
us in very valuable ways and then this
notion of salience what we pay attention
to you know what sorts of scripts are
going on in our head about ourselves and
others what are we paying attention to
how are we interpreting those in our
head and to others and then most
importantly perhaps to ourselves and
then our actual behavior is like what
are we doing from the time we wake up
until the time we go to sleep at night
and then our strivings our sense of
hopefulness
or perhaps lack of strivings and there I
am reminded also that
nobody does all of these things
perfectly all the time we all have
elements within us that perhaps are not
serving to geyser up into agency and
gratitude as well as they could
but that all of us have the capacity to
look
at these two pillars and these uh 10
things that were just listed off as you
describe them as cupboards that we look
into and examine and think about and
that if we can do that with a skilled
clinician like yourself or another
psychiatrist or psychologist terrific
but even if we don't have access to that
that we can examine within us what is
and is not serving to geyser up into
agency and gratitude we can bring any
issue of self to those two pillars and
the ten cupboards within them any issue
of self why because that's what it is
right in the sense that like it is is
the US what's inside of me I have an
unconscious mind I have a conscious mind
I have a defensive structure I have a
character structure I have a self I like
that's what it is right and all the
functions that you mentioned they're all
going on within that structure of self
they're manifesting themselves like
that's what it is when we're being right
in the active way of the verb
right that's what it is which is why we
can bring to it any issue of self even
though of course there's tremendous
complexity there you know the million
things that go on in a second you know
underneath the surface in the
unconscious mind and our defensive
structures and how to see them but we're
human beings we're complicated right
like that's okay because we have methods
of understanding we have methods of
inquiry and we can use those methods to
make things better
and that's how we make the geyser as
strong as it can be where like maybe
some maybe some some of the waters
running counter current in the in the
okay well let's try and have things go
all in the same direction but we don't
need things to be perfect for for the
geyser to spring up and the agency and
gratitude to then be uplifted upon it
so everybody has one of these Maps as I
understand it and therefore anytime
we're talking about relationships
romantic relationships or otherwise
we're talking about the intersection or
overlap of those maps in some way maybe
even the Synergy and the outgrowth of
those Maps becomes its own map I think
we'll get to this a little bit later yes
when I and most people hear the word
relationships in particular romantic
relationships I make a couple of
automatic assumptions uh first of all I
have to assume that people are either in
a relationship or out of a relationship
there's probably a third category out
there of plurals and other things but
we'll keep it relatively simple
and most people I assume when they
search for or enter or entered a
relationship
they thought about like whether or not
they had resonance with the person
whether or not you know there was a
intellectual or mutual interest
resonance or a physical resonance
um you know maybe something about family
history common goals Etc
um that's typically what people think
about and then perhaps if people will
have a bit more of a psychological
understanding or they're reading some
you know pop psychology books these days
you know some of which are are pretty
good
um they might understand something about
themselves or the other person being a
bit more anxious or a bit more relaxed
so you'll hear things like anxious
attached secure attached things of that
of that sort if we could just step back
from all of that for a moment and
examine it through the lens of the maps
as you're describing them which exist in
all of us and that really are the maps
to being the best version of ourselves
if we look at relationships in terms of
lists of you know where where people
went to school if they went to school
you know are their parents married or
divorced you know do they have trauma
that they're aware of or not aware of
these kinds of things I guess we could
call those uh and here I'm I'm borrowing
language that you used earlier uh off
camera so I want to acknowledge that
um you know points of compatibility like
like I think that seems like a
reasonable place to start right do
people want the same thing so if you if
you could uh could you talk a little bit
about points of compatibility in
relationship and how those show up
um For Better or For Worse when you
encounter people in the clinical setting
you know when you see a reli somebody
who's in a relationship that's really
working for them and is healthy versus
if they're in a relationship where it's
really unhealthy
um presumably there's some knowledge
about points of compatibility but I'm
guessing that's not always intuitive
right right I think the place we start
there is acknowledging what we can know
and what we can't know right so this
idea that there are levels of emergence
where where things at a lower level come
together and create something that's new
we see this throughout science from
subatomic particles all the way through
to culture right so someone could know
theoretically like lots and lots and
lots about you and lots and lots and
lots about me
but they don't know about us right like
they don't know how we interact they
don't know if we have shared interests
what we talk about right they they don't
know that no one knows that like we
don't know that
about the combination of people we can't
know it in advance but we we often
believe that we can which then leads to
a lot of false metrics of trying to
figure things out so when we're looking
for compatibility the thought would be
very basic tangible things like in
Romance for example if there's someone
who absolutely wants to have a family
and there's someone who absolutely does
not want to have a family okay that
would be a reason for those two people
to not choose one another right so there
are there are these factors but but the
factors are all in a sense very evident
and very concrete right if we go
if we go beyond that we say okay we can
see the obvious right then what we're
looking for is really a compatibility of
generative drives right and then that it
tells you can these people then get
along like you know maybe one of them is
from one side of the world and the
other's from the other side of the world
or one's an accountant and the other is
a musician and you know it doesn't mean
that oh like they're built not to get
along or that if they're doing the same
thing they're built to get along or if
they're they went to college in the same
place so they went to college versus not
going to college right there's so much
there that we we try to build a story on
and then what we do is we miss the
forest for the trees right and the trees
I think are the factors that don't
matter so again let's think about the
factors that do matter Chris wants to
have a family other person doesn't
that's relevant but the the trees that
mislead us might be do they have the
same level of Education uh do they have
the same family structure growing up are
parents still together uh what do they
enjoy are they creative or scientific or
whatever or creatively scientific right
we we could look at all of that but I
think then we're making a bunch of trees
that mislead us if you say look do these
people come at the world through how
much agency and gratitude is there
guiding them how you know how high is
the top of that geyser how high is it
uplifting that how strong is the
generative drive if we match people upon
that then we see oh those people got
along and those people didn't and then
you know they're all the other factors
like pheromones right and things that we
can't understand or like reflexive first
impression so so like we could let
things develop honoring the truth of
what we can't know that when you put two
people together you get something that's
different than the sum of both people
right it's not an overlap of maps right
it's a new map right and the map is
informed by things that are that are on
each individual's map but what we're
looking for are maps that don't have
very significant significant
differences around just clear concrete
things right but once we get beyond that
the maps can synergize in all sorts of
beautiful and unpredictable ways and if
both are are coming from the perspective
of a generative drive that is at the
Forefront great you put those Maps
together and see what happens maybe
nothing happens okay those people don't
go out on a second date you know maybe
something happens but it doesn't develop
in certain ways okay those people dated
and stop dating like this happens all
the time right but we set the odds in
our favor that the generative Drive in
each that is at the Forefront means that
their Maps can synergize in ways that
can then be beautiful and ways that can
maybe bring to both people that which
which they want and I think there's a
Simplicity to that that I I think if we
honor it it can be very very helpful
whether it's romances friendships of
looking at what the truth of it is
instead of the factors that we try and
gain a false sense of security if we're
we're using them to select upon you
mentioned several times
the generative drive and I definitely
would like to learn more about that and
spend some time there in the context of
relationships but just to drill a little
bit further into what we've all heard so
often and you touch upon a few of these
themes around points of compatibility
but also where uh sometimes we can
respond to the wrong things when
thinking about compatibility again we're
framing this mainly in the context of
hypothetical romantic relationships but
certainly it pertains to other sorts of
relationships things like
um you know is one person educated uh
with an advanced degree and is the other
person also you know we tend to assume
that people who are are somehow a better
match than people who aren't sort of an
implicit assumption that's often made
not always or that
um you know if two people really love
music that they will enjoy music
together and therefore you know some of
the whole is greater than either of its
parts you know and then and I think
those things are utterly irrelevant
interesting and I want to hear more
about this because I think that um if
you think about
um which I'm sure you don't but like
dating apps for instance like what's
listed out there or um first or second
dates which you know consists of like
learning a little bit about somebody and
what they're doing and maybe even a
little bit about their history and and
um maybe an activity uh and certainly an
intentional awareness to how the other
person is behaving in the context of
different things like you know a waiter
or a waitress and how they're treating
people and and you and and then you hear
about things like um what are the uh
this is not something I'm familiar with
oh right the um the love languages
people are like oh it's their Love
Languages you know it's like gifts or
like acts of physical
um uh touch or you know or acts of
service or something I I met someone
recently who and she told me my love
language is all of them you know which I
think is the most honest answer right
because sure there's probably some
waiting around what people value more or
less and in the absence of the things
they value the most it would probably
feel a bit like deprivation
um in any relationship but
as I'm describing all this I'm realizing
more and more yes all of that matters
anxious attached secure attached Love
Languages Etc but it really doesn't get
to the heart of the matter uh it really
doesn't get to this as you're describing
it this generative Drive in individuals
and whether or not those match up well
along the points of compatibility with
the other person's generative tribe and
you know I haven't run a controlled
study for this but the best evidence I
have is that there fortunately are many
people out there who are in happy
healthy relationships but there are many
many many people who are not either
because they can't find them or they're
in them and they're not healthy or
they're not happy
Etc so if you could um elaborate a bit
more on the generative drive again
reminding us what the nature of that is
we cover this a bit in episodes one and
two but what the nature of that is and
and some different ways that that's
expressed and how that shows up in
healthy relationship yeah yeah I think
we really disprove the idea that that
some of these these factors that I think
are superficial in the context of
whether people are going to be
compatible they're not superficial
things but they're not germane right so
let's say you think about music right
and say two people are contemplating
romance right and they both really like
music well that could go very very well
let's say they both have a a strong
generative drive those pillars are
pretty healthy and the geyser of the
agency and gratitude is riding upon it
and they can find peace in them in
themselves
um they're strongly generative then they
could become interested in the music the
other person likes isn't there's not
going to be a complete overlap right
even if people generally like the same
thing but they say they like different
things like just liking music or even
liking the same music there's still
difference right so the person has to go
beyond themselves right and say okay I'm
interested in like what you think even
about the music we both like right what
factors do you like there are places of
of learning and of growth for both and
you could see how both liking music
whether it's the same or different music
that sounds great right but you could
also see how that could not be great
right if if the generative Drive is too
low and the aggression Drive is too high
right then I'm gonna think I like music
my music's better than yours or you know
right or you know people then start
they'll fragment right even though they
have the same interest or if the
pleasure Drive is too high then they
think I want to listen to my music not
yours I I'm familiar with it instead of
hey I'm interested in that music because
because you're interested in it and I'm
interested in you right which leads us
to the second part let's say you have
someone who really has no interest in
music and someone who does well there
can be an openness of saying if I'm
interested in this person and this
person is really interested in music
like well that I have some interest in
it right I want to learn something about
it I want to experience some of it with
the other person and let's say that
person then finds hey that's not my
thing it's not the thing we connect on
then why would that be the end of the
world right people one person goes to
concerts the other doesn't right so you
know we we try and find these points of
commonality because I think we get over
reductionist and then we think oh here's
a bunch of factors that we will identify
and what they do is they obscure us from
the primary factor which is the
generative Drive which of course will
then induce open-mindedness
mentalization if I don't like music and
you do instead of saying
what does he like music for you know I I
need a friendship with somebody likes
music you know you think hey like that's
interesting like if I'm interested in
you as a friend and I have respect for
you and what you think then
why would I not have some interest in
what you're interested in you know so so
this idea of compatibility revolves
around the health in each person it
doesn't revolve around factors that are
anything but the concrete logistical
factors that would just keep two people
apart
I love the idea that healthy
relationships center around the factors
that really matter within the self right
in particular the generative drive and I
and I love the example of someone being
able to be curious about somebody's
interests about their partner's
interests even though they might not
share those
um
from the standpoint of agency and
gratitude because the agency component
there is really key I think that a lot
of people feel as if they aren't really
good at something or really
knowledgeable about something then
it's not for them right which is the
opposite of having agency and gratitude
because gratitude is closely tied to
humility you know how could we know
everything it can be good certain things
and not others so the way you describe
it includes aspects of openness of
humility but also the agency side the
empowerment like if I'm going to learn
more than perhaps you know we could
enjoy more of that together perhaps not
right I think um this is what I'm
sensing and I'm also sensing that um the
words like-minded you know like-minded
people has so much more to do with their
generative drives and how those match up
as opposed to the activities that they
prefer engaging in and the sorts of
foods they like or the movies they like
and um which
makes sense at some level but I think it
is still counterintuitive for for a lot
of us who um just kind of reflexively
think oh like they like the same things
you know or maybe that maybe even they
met at work because they like the same
type of work
um they like to live in a certain area
of the country and therefore by
proximity they met and this raises all
sorts of
um interesting ideas perhaps about
um the statistics of what we see right
like two musicians together
um we therefore assume that musicians
belong together or two scientists
together I know loads of scientists
scientists couples or scientists
physician couples and
um but of course the numbers are skewed
because they were working in
environments where it increased the
probability they would interact so this
is actually a vote for online dating in
some sense because it breaks through all
those
um sometimes even geographical barriers
but certainly the the traditional
barriers of culture right right and if
you think about we're talking about
relationships so I would like my
relationships to last as long as
possible Right that means now we're
talking about my lifespan and my health
span right like that's then becomes part
of that discussion and of course we're
very interested in lifespan and health
span and we see people do much much
better when they're interconnected in
the world around them when they're still
learning new things like we know that's
true that people often will tell the
sort of Trail off of of what they're
learning whether it's it's music it's
literature it's the world around us you
know relatively early in our lifespan
but the person who's interconnected
learning new things right has a much
greater probability of living longer and
living healthier right so I think what's
that about it's about a generative drive
right it's about you know what I've
learned a lot of things over the course
of my life and I'm 80 years old now and
like great that there's more to learn
right and like that's what you see it
makes me think of a woman who's around
90 years old in my practice she's always
learning new things like she's super
interested in things things and I'm
always struck about how like she seems
so much younger right and and there
that's not just a selection bias like oh
I just happen to see that in that person
like she has the factors that predispose
to Aging in the way that's healthiest
and happiest so it really comes down the
root of all of it in ourselves in our
relationships in the quality of them
over time and how long we get to have
them really arises from a generative
drive and that's the thing that makes us
then
undefended right and lets us find
interest in things about other people
that are different from the things in us
which also comes about naturally like I
think it's interesting that we have this
sort of bias like the musicians belong
together well why they're familiar with
the same things right I guess they have
the same interest same thing with
Scientists but then a lot of people like
different foods right like I love
different ethnic foods like why because
it's different right it's it's an
appreciation of difference I don't want
to just like I did Growing Up and many
many people are like that that's an
appreciation of difference of diversity
so sometimes we'll kind of harness that
and we'll look at it and we'll say oh
like that's present in us but for
whatever reason we become very
reductionist about relationships and now
we're trying to match based upon
sameness right and like sameness
is is not the point of it I mean they're
even thoughts right about people then in
some ways seeking difference right and
maybe pheromones are telling us like I
actually know very little about that but
I certainly know that striving for
sameness doesn't make good things happen
in relationships you know I've been
doing this for over 20 years and and
like I I don't see that the alleged
factors of sameness matter again unless
they're so concrete like if this person
is absolutely going to live in North
America and that person's absolutely
going to live in South America let's not
potentially put them together but once
we get away from almost that level of
concreteness let's look for something
different and then like everything else
it simplifies
right the higher we go up the latter the
more simple things get if you're looking
at the pillars structure of cell
function of self you're creating the
agency and gratitude then what are you
looking for when you're looking for a
partner a match in generative Drive
I want to I want mine to be strong and I
see that it's strong in this person they
create in a way you know I I do science
they grow a garden
regenerative together right like that
could be super compatible because we're
looking at the one factor that really
matters I'd like to take a brief break
and acknowledge one of our sponsors ag1
ag1 is a vitamin mineral probiotic drink
that meets all of your foundational
nutrition needs I started taking ag1 way
back in 2012. so I'm delighted that
they're sponsoring the podcast the
reason I started taking ag1 and the
reason I still take ag1 once or
generally twice per day is that it's the
easiest way for me to ensure that I'm
getting all of the vitamins minerals
probiotics and fiber that I need in my
diet now of course it's essential to get
proper nutrition from Whole Foods but
most people including myself find it
hard to get enough servings of fruits
and vegetables each day and especially
to get enough prebiotics and probiotics
to ensure gut health as you may know
your gut contains trillions of little
microbiota the so-called gut microbiome
which establishes critical connections
with other organs of your body to
enhance brain health as well as to
support your immune system and other
aspects that relate to mental and
physical health one of the most common
questions I get is if you were to take
Just One supplement which supplement
would that be and my answer is always
ag1 because by taking ag1 I'm able to
ensure that I'm getting all of the
vitamins minerals and probiotics that I
need to enhance my mental health
physical health and performance if you'd
like to try ag1 go to drinkag1.com
huberman to claim a special offer
they'll give you five free travel packs
and they'll give you a year's supply of
vitamin D3 K2 again that's drink ag1.com
huberman to claim this special offer
I'm realizing that most of what I and
everyone else has heard about
relationships is complete nonsense I
really mean that I mean it has occurred
to me before because I've experienced
both that the phrases absence makes the
heart grow fonder
and out of sight out of mind are in
direct contradiction with one another so
they're both true depends on the
circumstances and you know who the hell
knows why it could right you also hear
Opposites Attract but they don't stay
together
right you hear similar you know the
important thing is to find someone
similar to you that that or that there's
like one person right that's right I
mean these are if we really think about
it crazy right Notions yes but they
drive a lot of what people think about
relationships right they drive angst
right they drive bad choices they drive
uh situations that then create a sense
of guilt and shame and inadequacy like
we mislead ourselves by not going to the
basics of what is actually true like let
me look at myself make myself as healthy
as I can be right because if I'm healthy
I'll recognize a lack of Health in the
other right so it also protects us
against bad relationships and then if
I'm going to make myself healthy which
we're describing how that looks wouldn't
I want someone who also wants to make
themselves healthy or at least if we're
gonna Ally right let's let's Ally around
making both of of ourselves healthier
absolutely and we're going to go deeper
into how to look into the map of self
and how that relates to relationship uh
certainly more as we go along this uh
discussion
you've mentioned several times however
about generative drive and that it
really is the definition of like-minded
in some sense
and you also mentioned aggressive drives
and pleasure drives themes that we
touched on again in episodes one and two
but listening to those episodes is
certainly not necessary to digest what
we're talking about today
could you go a little bit deeper into
the generative Drive flesh out for us
what that is
um I think generative I think generator
I think energy I hear aggression or
aggressive Drive I think as I think most
people do um friction maybe even
conflict
maybe physical conflict maybe verbal
conflict but I know it's some of that
perhaps but a whole lot more and then
pleasure drive and pleasure some people
think Bliss some people think Delight
um some people probably have all sorts
of specific things they think of with
respect to pleasure so if you just flush
those out for us a little bit more
because I think those are going to serve
as
um cornerstones of today's discussion
sure so drives and in this case the
generative Drive sort of exists within
us and what they do is they're defining
potential right so so right now one
could argue if we just pause for a
couple seconds we're not doing anything
generative in those seconds right but
then we resume doing something that we
believe is generative right so at the
time we're pausing that's when we can
sort of look at that as a drive within
us to to to make new learning right to
understand things we didn't understand
before to spread a sense of goodness
right so it resides in us in a way that
is determined by a whole bunch of
different factors like like everything
else that's determined within us there's
a nature and a nurture component so some
aspect of it or what are the genetics
that came down to us what are formative
experiences but we can go in and alter
that so if we see the drive as a set of
potentials like in that moment we pause
there's a set of potentials within us
like potential of where we can take our
thoughts our actions our Reflections our
decisions right that's the drive within
us and it exists within us in a way that
we could localize now like if we think
enough about okay how much of a
generative Drive is there in a person
how much is that person looking to the
to to make a better life for themselves
or a better world around them and how do
they feel about themselves and their
ability to do that how generative are
they or how shut down or demoralized or
envious so we can in a sense localize
that and again the localization has
these genetic and nurture components to
it but we can then go and influence that
and that's the that's the importance if
the drive is a set of potentials a set
of possibilities then that drive is one
in the same pervaded with however we
want to to to describe that with the
agency and gratitude because the agency
and gratitude is sort of the operative
form of that that's the verb right it's
the drive actually driving something
right so if you have a strong generative
drive then agency and gratitude are
leading the decisions the reflections
are coming through that the aggression
within us or again that's the this the
historical word but we can say
aggression assertion proactive
proactiveness right all of this inside
of us and our drive for pleasure for
gratification right that all is then
it's in us but it's observing the
generative Drive meaning the generative
drive that set of potentials and
possibilities is dominant which of
course makes sense with agency and
gratitude those active verbs being what
is most active right and then we're also
going to feel at times and hopefully at
a lot of times right the that set of
peacefulness that sense of contentment
the sense of delight right what you're
describing when you're you know doing
the podcast and you're in it and all
these good things are happening to you
right there's a strong generative Drive
in you that set of potentials are being
actualized through the verbs of agency
and gratitude like you're doing it all
right then and as you're doing it you
have a sense of peace and contentment as
you're enacting all of it and then that
makes you healthier reinforces the
generative drive it protects you against
the next sling or Arrow of Outrageous
Fortune that will come your way right
you become more self-knowledgeable more
you become stronger right and and
ultimately that's what we're looking for
like that's the state of goodness and I
believe that if you look historically
what is it that we're seeking we can put
so many words to it and we're choosing
to put these words to it I mean I think
that this is the structure because I
think the science the history the
clinical experience the phenomenology I
think it all tells us this we can put
different words to it but what we're
looking at when we're looking at truth
and how to get to the happiness quote
unquote that that people have sought
Through the Ages I mean I think we know
enough now we've learned enough that we
can say oh this is what it looks like
and it fits the Arbiter of all truth
which is as you get further up the
hierarchy it gets simpler that's true
about humans what's going on in my
unconscious is is very very complicated
right but if that's something to as we
get higher up to like I'm approaching
the world with a lot of agency and
gratitude right that's a lot simpler and
that's what can be be common among us
which is why if my pillars are very
different from your pillars and what
we've struggled against each is very
different and what we may still have to
work against is very different well we
can be extremely compatible as friends
because are we are we working on
ourselves are we fostering the
generative drive so we're coming at the
world in that way an agency and
gratitude that's the similarity right
between us that matters and ultimately
we're looking at the potential that
every moment we're building the
potential in us for what comes at the
next moment which is why we're
describing the overlap the point of
commonality that really matters that
matters we're putting a label to it
right we're saying it's the generative
drive but it is also that okay we both
come at the world through agency and
gratitude you know if two people are
assessing compatibility but if we're
looking at something to Nest that under
and what seems most logical is the set
of potentials within us that were bill
building and altering each moment and
then as I alter it in this moment right
it's altered and it affects my next
moment right if I do something that's
just kind of thoughtless to somebody you
know because I'm in a I'm in a bad mood
right then what am I doing I'm
projecting out my aggression I'm doing
something that basically makes me less
than right and then I'm gonna feel less
in the next moment whether that moment
is about me or is about someone else the
drives are the Potentials in us but we
are actively working on them determining
them changing them each moment
I'm well on board the idea that the uh
the typical pairings uh let's call them
the idiosyncratic pairings of you know
musician with musician in many cases but
you know sometimes very verbal person
with quieter person you know introvert
with extrovert or introvert with
introvert that all of that takes
backseat or it perhaps even back back
seat and perhaps it even is out of the
vehicle compared to the critical
importance of generative drive right
when we think about generative drives
and individuals you beautifully
described what a generative Drive is and
how it shows up in individuals
when thinking about generative drives in
romantic relationships however
because generative Drive can be
expressed to varying degrees
does one often see that or do you think
that a matching of sort of levels of
generative drives is what Fosters the
best relationships in other words let's
say somebody has a pretty high pleasure
drive
but not a very strong aggressive also
Pro also called proactiveness drive and
so maybe like they're um they watch a
lot of Netflix like a lot of Netflix but
they're not even the sort of person
that's like really excited about the
shows and telling you about them because
there's a version of watching a lot of
Netflix where the person is
um really interested in learning and
knowing maybe even they're thinking
about writing a writing something you
know poetry or book or they're bringing
some of that to their life right I
mentioned it that way because watching
Netflix isn't bad per se right it's not
anti-generative is it an escape or is it
generative is a person thinking about
what they're going to do they're going
to write that book or are they just
trying to numb out and at the end of
five hours in front of the television
they don't know what those five hours
were right there's no intrinsic value
judgment based upon a lot of things that
we make intrinsic value we make value
judgments about right you have to look
at who is the person what is the context
are they being generative or not yeah
some of the movies and shows that I've
watched in relationships became the the
points of connection around
at least to me tremendously interesting
discussions on Hikes that we took the
next day and um and Reflections on our
own relationship and work in life and so
I'm so glad that you point out that
there's nothing intrinsically valuable
or or invaluable about something like
Netflix
um or even intrinsically passive about
doing right something like sitting
around or even reading books for that
matter there's a passive version of
reading great books also people forget
that it's hard to read a great book and
not learn something I guess that's why
they're called great books but um but
there is a version of that I know many
people people want to possess the book I
read the book and I'm going to check it
off I don't know what was in it like
people do that that is not generative so
should we consider matching of level or
expression of generative drives
as
perhaps the what we are all seeking in
seeking relationship like that and do
you think that people tend to pair up
um naturally pair up with people that
have a similar level of generative drive
or if they don't
do you think it leads to problems right
yeah I think that by and large people
don't that it's not the thing that we're
thinking about and looking for in
ourselves or others and I absolutely
believe that it makes problems and let's
take a look to not look it makes
problems to not look right it makes
sense right the fact that we're not
basing it upon generative drive it does
indeed I think make many many many many
many many and in fact countless problems
and I would take as an example think
about the idea of a trauma Bond right a
trauma bond is not a bad thing
that sounds like a strong statement
because the way that I hear traumabond
used is it's a bad thing right but it
doesn't have to be so so let's take a
look at it imagine that you have what
people call a trauma Bond you know you
have two people who let's just make up a
situation right they're they're
functioning in the world around them but
they each have had some very significant
trauma that is creating issues in them
so let's say they're avoidance issues a
person doesn't feel safe or comfortable
in the world around them they get
invited to places that they'd like to go
but they don't go right they want to go
to the museum and see something really
new and cool there but there might be a
crowd right I mean this happens right
let's say you have two people who both
have this in them it could be because
the trauma is similar the trauma could
be night and day right but they each
have this in them they could bond around
that trauma in a way that worsens the
trauma that's why why people think
negatively of a trauma Bond right so if
the case is that the trauma bond is not
a good thing for these two people you
say why is that it's not because both of
them have had trauma and both of them
are impacted by trauma and both of them
are impacted by trauma in similar ways
it's not that it's that the drives are
not in a healthy place and the
gratification of the generative drive
and the pleasure drives are not high
enough so let's imagine the generative
Drive is could be relatively low in in
each of these people and one or the
other or
they could have a naturally high drive
that's being thwarted right so so
there's something that's out of balance
where the drive is the the ability to
express the drive right is there enough
agency right if there's not like let's
say one person is really really shut
down that person can't stand their job
right okay something is shutting that
person down the generative Drive wishes
greater expression they go back and look
at themselves you can bring that into
line right but something is out of
balance at the time the the pleasure
Drive may be low or it may be high but
it may not be gratified it may be that
that person loves museums and wants to
go to the museum but can't find that
gratification right that's a possibility
the aggression or assertion drive would
be on the low end right but it could be
higher maybe if that person felt safer
right that drive within them has a lot
of latitude and maybe it could move
higher right but something is out of
balance in the drives and in their
expression right that's the problem
because let's look at the other side
where a trauma bond is a great thing
right so each of the people in the
example has trauma and they recognize it
in themselves and they understand how it
makes things harder for them and and
then that they're communicating about
how it makes it hard in the other right
so maybe there's a lot of overlap right
in Social avoidance and sense of
vulnerability but maybe there are things
that are different in one person versus
the other so then they can come together
and say look the what's the goal of life
like I would like to be as healthy as I
can be I'm working on myself you want to
be as healthy as you can be we want to
be as healthy as we can be and if we're
healthy we also help each of us be
healthy so maybe those two people
neither of which they would ever go to
the museum on their own because the
trauma inside of them is at a point it
hasn't been worked through or it's at a
place where they just simply feel too
vulnerable right but together they can
go to the museum and then the bond
around trauma helps them be healthy the
drives are in a better place because
they're able to recognize hey there are
things going on in me that I'd like to
be different and better and you
recognize that too and we can talk about
it with one another right so they're in
a healthier place and then from that
healthier place they build greater
health
so much of what we hear about in terms
of friction points in relationships
centers around it seems
communication or lack of communication
and as you're describing the role of the
generative Drive in healthy relationship
it seems to me that it ties back in
every way to agency and gratitude and
agency being such a critical element of
communication because wherever you've
identified that okay there's a potential
problem here
um people with high generative Drive in
these examples seem to be capable of
like
self-inquiry uh asking the other person
questions that bring bring them closer
together into a deeper understanding of
the self I raise this because one thing
that's often overheard or that I've
overheard I of course have siblings and
friends or or um and I'll place this in
the the way that I've most typically
heard it but I'm sure it exists other
ways too which is um uh in that the
conversation in my head is one where a
woman is saying you know like they're
with somebody
um or dating somebody and like he's he's
so clueless like I wish that he would
just do this thing sometimes these are
acts of chivalry like maybe it's flowers
or vacations but more often than not
it's it's
um a request or a complaint about a lack
of proactiveness you know this is also
what ratchets up to these um very pan
statements that you hear like oh there's
no real men these days or like there are
no real men left or you know this kind
of thing you also hear it in the reverse
right you hear men making pan statements
about women
and here we're doing this in the context
of heterosexual pairings but of course
it could all work just as well right
it's exactly it could all work
um in the context of homosexual pairings
too so you hear those sorts of things
and it sounds like a lack of
communication you know okay maybe one
person needs to be better at asking for
their needs to be met maybe the other
person needs to develop more of an
awareness of what the other person needs
of course we all seem to kind of
intrinsically wish that um things would
just happen for us without the the need
to request them or ask for them but I'm
realizing again that all of that is is
distracting commotion because that's not
really what's going on what what's
really going on it seems is that the
engine behind communication the engine
behind curiosity a desire to learn and
know and create something from that
learning and knowing in the relationship
the generative Drive is really what's
the issue or the lack of generative
drive in any of those conversations it
seems one could Circle back to that and
go okay well someone's not asking the
right questions and therefore not doing
the right things because they're they
don't either have a sense of agency or
they don't have gratitude for the
situation they're in including their own
ability to do that right so when you
hear you know people aren't showing up
for the relationship they're not showing
up or you know she's not showing up or
again let's make the pan statement go in
the other direction that you know
um
that somebody just wants a lot of
attention right they just need an excess
amount of attention won't let me do my
own thing but also wants me to work and
be successful you know again these are
stereotypes but all of that seems very
distracting however all of it
seems far simpler if we push it through
this filter of generative drives and
whether or not it's being expressed yes
yes I think maybe the best example of
this because it's so highly charged is
imagine that the pleasure drive through
the lens of sex and sexuality right so
imagine that people are in a pairing
they're in a relationship regardless of
how they got they were taking people are
in a relationship and one has a a sex
drive with which means an interest in
sex and maybe uh proclivities for a
diversity of sexual experience that say
if we just for sake of this example we
put on a one to ten scale that that
person is a two okay now is it the other
person in the 10 being the greatest yeah
sorry sorry tell me right that person is
a two now let's say the partner is an
eight okay so so there's a big mismatch
there you think how does that normally
go
the two stays at two the eight stays in
eight and things don't go well right it
creates friction in the relationship at
a minimum it blows the relationship
apart at a maximum the person who's a
two feels inadequate often I mean it's
not always right but but this is how the
softening goes person who's a two feels
inadequate because the person who's
innate wants either more or different
right and the person is who's it too
doesn't now that person feels bad and
they may feel bad about themselves or
resentful of the person with a higher
sex drive the person on the higher level
feels not resentful of the person at the
lower level or maybe they feel like
there's something wrong with them
because their sex drive's too high or
they have an interest that that the
other person doesn't have and now they
start labeling themselves like this
happens all the time and it doesn't
change most of the time and the problems
are enormous okay so so let's see how
could that look how would that look with
really high generative drives and
therefore the ability to think think
about self to think about others and to
think about the US of the situation
right the two people together right so
they be able to talk about it in ways
that
wouldn't be faulting of the other and
would acknowledge what's inside of them
like the person with the lower Drive
could say you know it just the things
that doesn't strike me as more
interesting I don't think about it more
they could talk about all of that the
person who wishes more or wishes
different could talk about that too
right and could talk about what they
feel inside if there's a frustration of
that just like the person with the lower
sex drive could talk about how
frustrating it feels to feel pressured
right so what are they developing
they're mentalizing right they're
thinking about each other's emotional
states and and they're coming at each
other through agency and gratitude like
I'm so grateful for you remember see
we're the example is these people are
partners and they're happy with their
partnership like oh my God I'm so
grateful I found you right they would
each feel that way I'm so grateful
you're in my life like this happens too
right and then from that lens you know
the two isn't going to become an eight
the eight isn't going to become a two
right but in general in situations like
this there can be somewhere in the
middle right and and let's say that you
you know people says okay you know what
I can get out of my comfort zone a
little bit why don't most people try
that because they feel embarrassed they
feel self-conscious you know they they
don't want to try new things or try more
like people get closed down because
there's such shame around sexuality you
can take people on any spectrum of
sexuality and you will find shame you
know not in every person but across
whatever population we're looking at
because it's so emotionally charged so
let's say in a loving caring
relationship you're like that person
feels the freedom inside say you know
what maybe I could enjoy sex a little
more a little more often a little more
Innovative that person thinks about like
somebody who's at it too can then move
that to a different place you know a
little bit more or maybe even a lot more
depending and then the person who's at
the higher level you know the eight
doesn't need another eight right in
order to stay in the relationship but
but something maybe more than a two
right and then let's say they come into
the middle and then the person who's
innate realizes like look I love you and
you love me and and you you out of your
comfort zone right in order to do this
and like and wow and it's like more fun
for both of us so like you know what
it's okay my higher sex traffic I'll
deal with that that maybe just making it
up like I I would like to do it three
times a week we're doing it too okay you
know what that that's fine both sides
can live with it but it is not fredbear
it's not like well they can live with it
it's like no number one they can live
with it number two it's better
it's better right the two at one point
was thinking hey anything more than a
two is I can't do that right it's shut
down on the eight doesn't want anything
less than an eight now they're in the
middle and their relationship is closer
that's real that happens what is it
relying upon it's relying upon
degenerative drive to have the openness
the ability to communicate maybe the
person who's innate say has a sexual
proclivity they're embarrassed about
that happens all the time too but in the
sense of acceptance of self and and the
belief in the the strength of the
relationship and the acceptance of the
other you know people can Broach things
most people who feel like oh I could
never approach that it's not something
bizarre or dangerous like it's not
something that in a relationship that's
that's defined by the generative Drive
the other person is likely to reject so
let's define our relationships through
the generative drive and let's cultivate
in self and others the most generative
drive if somehow let's say person a and
person B here because it doesn't matter
who's the A and who's the two has
cultivated more of a generative drive
then maybe that person could give more
to the other before that person can give
back to them you know we we have these I
I think this
completely nonsensical ideas about
mutuality right the idea that even in a
situation that's supposed to be defined
by love right and you know friendship is
a form of love right so friendship
um a collaborative uh Endeavor right
they're like these they have they have
some affection in them right friendship
can have love and often does and let's
say the love of of romance that there's
supposed to be some equality right you
know the idea that well if I'm going to
give something I want you to give
something to look it is not good if one
person is always doing the giving things
are out of balance but it is very
healthy to be able to say
you know if I can give something and
you're not in a place to give something
let me just give something to you right
people don't always or maybe don't often
depend on how we want to look at it give
to others with a sense of Freedom like
and you don't owe me anything either
right why because it comes from love it
comes from the abundance the the access
of goodness in me coming through the the
the agency that I feel the gratitude
that I feel and then what's more likely
you're much more likely the other person
right to to sort of feel like hey I can
go a little more you feel stronger you
feel empowered making someone feel worse
or saying you know what I can give you
something but you owe me something back
right even if that's tacit right well
I'll give you know I can give you this
now but you kind of know that the other
person could end up doing the laundry
for two months or something like this is
not okay why not just give something
right you're giving goodness and then
the other person actually gets the
goodness and they're more likely to find
it within themselves right to to then
come a little out of their comfort zone
develop you know move their generative
drive a little bit forward so so gifts
given to others with no expectation of
return are Gifts of abundance or gifts
that arise from the generative drive and
they make us more generative think about
the opposite what often happens each
person makes the other feel guilty right
right oh this person wants he wants so
much and look there you are again like
people feel terrible about that or you
know there you don't want any sex or
this or that the other person feels
terrible like
that's why the two stays the 2 and the
eight stays the eight right but it
doesn't have to be that way and it's
also not that if both end up in the
middle say both are a five that that's
some compromised position that implies
less no that's the compromised position
that makes more I'd like to take a brief
break and acknowledge our sponsor eight
sleep eight sleep makes Smart mattress
covers with cooling Heating and sleep
tracking capacity I've spoken many times
before on this podcast and elsewhere
about the fact that getting a quality
night's sleep on a regular basis is the
foundation of mental health physical
health and performance when we're
sleeping well everything goes better
when we are not sleeping well or enough
everything in terms of mental health
physical health and performance gets far
worse very quickly one of the key things
to getting a great night's sleep is to
control the temperature of your sleeping
environment and that's because in order
to fall and stay deeply asleep you need
your core body temperature to drop by
about one to three degrees and in order
to wake up feeling refreshed you need
your core body temperature to increase
by about one to three degrees that all
becomes very easy when using an eight
sleep mattress cover because it allows
you to program the temperature of your
sleeping environment at the beginning
middle and towards the end of your night
when you wake up I started sleeping on
an eight-sleep mattress cover over two
years ago and it immediately and
persistently improved the quality and
depth of my sleep and as a consequence I
wake up feeling far more refreshed I
have enhanced mood focus and alertness
throughout the day if you'd like to try
eight sleep you can go to eightsleep.com
huberman to save up to 150 off their pod
3 cover each sleep currently ships in
the USA Canada UK select countries in
the EU and Australia again that's
eightsleep.com huberman based on my
understanding of the generative Drive
the aggressive also we're calling it
proactiveness drive in the pleasure
drive and the
importance of the generative Drive being
greater than the aggressive or pleasure
drives I can also see the potential
problem of having like two eights along
the sexual desire scale or two nines
um or two tens and actually I've
observed a lot of examples of this uh
for instance if they're let's say two
nines they're put both people nine out
of ten on the on the joy and uh sort of
proclivity for sex Adventure sex Etc on
they're very high on the pleasure scale
perhaps even so much so that they don't
pay attention to or one person doesn't
pay attention to
the critical need for
points of compatibility to be met like
the desire to someday have a family I've
known couples like this
they're together for a long time they
seem to really enjoy one another I know
nothing of their sex lives but there
just seems to be a very strong
attachment around certain forms of
pleasure that they both enjoy engaging
in so this could be activities or travel
I mean here we're saying you know nine
out of ten on on the sex scale but
in many of those cases there's one
person saying you know but I want to
have a family someday and they're just
not into that or perhaps even like but
he won't leave his wife
right you know they're like involved in
something that feels really good they're
matching along some set pleasure to
drive but completely overlooking the
larger goals of one or both people right
and um in it you know here I pointed to
an instance of infidelity uh that's its
own you know issues with morals Etc but
you see this a lot like people really
orienting towards what feels good and
who feels good to be with and that of
course is healthy but that's not the
entire picture so would you say that
what I'm describing is an example of
where the pleasure drive has overcome
the generative drive because in the case
of somebody wanting a family and the
other person already having one and
being unwilling to leave that one or the
other person not wanting a family uh
that the generative Drive of the the
person who uh who wants a family is is
not being respected it's or it's being
undermined by this excess desire for
pleasure like they're just drawn into
the moment and the the amazing weekends
and they're but this person is
incredible and they're charismatic and
um I can't tell you how many times I've
had friends say that um you know they
are they admire the person they're with
but they know their relationship can't
work because of all these other
underlying issues right right right
right right and it's it's interesting we
both
overestimate and underestimate what say
love can do right people so love can do
anything no if I spill that glass love's
not going to put the water back in it
right if I must live in North America
and my partner must live in South
America like we're not going to be okay
right so we say these things in a very
Wishful way love will overcome
everything like this doesn't overcome
that right
or maybe it does in the right
circumstances so think about if the
generative Drive
is very
very high right in both people so both
people have say a strong need to live in
a certain place they can find a
compromised position maybe they live
half the year in North America and half
in South America but why because in that
situation the love between them which
which is the generative Drive in the
relationship right so what does that
mean the first person has to have a
strong generative Drive be healthy
understand that even though I I need to
live in North America right doesn't does
it actually mean that do I really need
to live in North America right I have to
be able to see Beyond Myself and what
does that mean to the person I love who
needs to live on the other side of the
world if the other person can do that
too then in the relationship right which
is a new entity right it emerges from
one person and the other you can know
everything about one person everything
about the other
you don't know about the two of them
together right so the two of them
together are an us and if that us has a
strong generative Drive which it can if
if each person has a strong generative
Drive they can bring to the state of
emergence of the US the generative drive
and that's the we're talking about a
relationship so say the love between
them and they can find a way through so
the idea that like love hears all things
like which is fine what does that
actually mean right it doesn't mean we
have a lot of pleasure together right or
we like a lot of the same things like
that's not what that means and people
can very very much love one another but
not be aware of the limitations inside
of them right because maybe there are
other things going on in them like say
childhood trauma they love one another
but they can't get out of their comfort
zone enough right so the point is if we
make each ourselves as healthy as we can
be and then two cells come together that
are making themselves as healthy as they
can be then the US between between them
really can fit that definition of of
love and do anything but we have to
Define that in the right way in a way
that honors the truth which again is not
a higher degree of complexity it's
actually more simple so you gave an
example of a romantic relationship where
one person has a strong sex drive and
the other a weaker drive and then we
talked about an example where both
people have a essentially high sex drive
and where that could potentially be
beneficial assuming that the generative
Drive is also high in both of them
and we also explored a little bit of how
it can be bad for a relationship if it
exceeds the generative Drive
what about the aggressive proactiveness
Drive how does that show up in romantic
parents you know if one person has a
high proactiveness AKA aggressive drive
and the other person does not
um what does that look like and and do
you see that often in your clinical
practice sure sure
if this makes sense maybe we look at
that example of the person who's a two
and the person who's innate on the on
the sex drive scale right you'd say okay
the person who's a two who's trying to
to raise that right has a strong
generative Drive what does that mean the
person thinks you know what I think I
can do this I can set myself about this
I see it it will make my relationship
better like I'm going to give it a try
that's the generative Drive In Action
the pleasure Drive the person may look
at that and say look maybe this can be
more fun for me right like has it been
that fun for me if I have a low pleasure
Drive could I start enjoying this more
and then maybe that moves up right or
maybe I have a higher pleasure drive but
it's not been gratified because I
haven't been able to be open and honest
like let me see if I can make that
better
then what's active what the person is
doing is then going to the aggressive or
assertive proactive right to that drive
and going to the potential in that drive
and Mining some of what's in it like
yeah how am I going to do that I'm going
to bring myself to bear
right and like that's not an easy thing
it's not like that person then all of a
sudden decides to be more sexual right
there have to be a lot of communication
between the two people a lot of
discussion of what what setting might be
best for that what helps the person feel
understood or feel more comfortable like
there's a lot then to do there and the
person may even need to go back to the
pillars right because the person may
feel like whoa
I don't think I can do that right and
then it is that's not good I want to do
that right what is it that I can't do
there's a realization there and then
maybe the person who's an aide because
they're so well connected gets it okay
you can't do that like let me support
you right in whatever way while you're
figuring that out because they're both
generative they want to figure that out
now oh sorry it's interrupt when you say
you go back to the pillars you mean go
back to exploring the structure of
themselves and their function of
themselves so that they can
um for instance get some insight into
what sorts of defense mechanisms might
be in place right um what they're paying
attention to or their behaviors like
maybe even health related behaviors that
could be impacting their sex drive but
but maybe even things that
um reside at a deeper level the
unconscious mind you know talking to
somebody till they make a connection
around uh shame or or or some story that
they've integrated into their thinking
at a subconscious level right right just
an example that I see a lot is avoidance
where okay not always but let's say the
person with who's the two on the sex
drive scale who finds like I can't do it
right wow I just can't bring myself to
do it right and then they go back and
they explore this happens up this
happens a lot where there's avoidance
and then we get curious about the
avoidance like because the person's like
I just there's something to be just I
don't want
to do that right okay so there's
avoidance we identify avoidance we also
identify that it's not healthy because
the person does actually want to do that
because it's it's good for the
relationship and it could be good for
them too and then maybe we start looking
at unconscious mind right or conscious
mind right and maybe we don't find
because it's easy now if I said oh
there's a major trauma that the person
hasn't processed sometimes it's that but
a lot of times it's not that you know
maybe that person just never learned to
feel comfortable with sexuality or maybe
the way that they experience or or are
attracted to sexuality was disparaged or
denigrated right or you know they had
some bad feeling about it because the
society and the culture told them that
or maybe they had a couple bad
experiences where they were treated in a
certain way and then it's like okay that
person comes by that honestly there's
not a major trauma there in fact
unfortunately there's a trauma that's
almost predictable from the way our
society you know has been structured so
a person can go look at that I'm like
right like I never I never learned how
to do this how to be comfortable with
this or you know what I learned that I'm
not good at it or I I learned that no
one will enjoy it with me but but that's
not true like these are these are
situations not in the side of a loving
relationship right now that person is
able to bring that knowledge to Bear
whether it came from the unconscious
mind or the conscious mind and then
that's how you work to start shifting
things like that was then this is now
right it is not then when say the person
say in high school had a sexuality that
others didn't approve of and made them
feel bad well guess what it's not then
and like that's unfortunate it's wrong
it's unjust we're going to honor and
validate all that that is but we're also
going to look at that that was then this
is now and you get to behave differently
now you're an adult now and adults get
to choose their relationships and you
chose a good relationship right so so
this is the kind of thing that can that
can get that person to the point where
they can go back up through now what
happens at the end of it the geyser is
stronger there there's more agency
there's more of a sense of gratitude
right why because the person can attach
themselves more to I'm so lucky to have
this person as opposed to damn it I wish
that person didn't have a higher sex
drive right so the person and they feel
better about themselves instead of
what's wrong with me that I don't have a
higher sex drive right or I said They
wish the other person had a lower sex
drive I wish they had a higher sex drive
that's not grateful like I'm grateful I
am who I am and that I have any sex
drive at all and I'm grateful for this
other person now through through that
like that change right they can go back
and better access the assertion the the
the proactive Drive the aggressive drive
whatever we want to call it because
they've taken away they've gone and
worked through the barrier to it then
they're able to be a little more out of
their comfort zone and the the other
person meets them there right and and
they start having this this you know
this healthy thing between them where
the US that is them the love between
them gets better right and then where do
they find themselves that's how they get
to the five when which is not a
compromise between eight and two that
satisfies neither it is a compromise
between eight and two that is way better
for both and for the relationship
I'm curious about common pairings That
You observe in the clinical setting and
not to focus on the bad but
if there are common pairings that rarely
lead to a good outcome
I think it's worth us learning about
those simply because they're common and
they lead to a bad outcome
and a discussion of this sort could
potentially help people avoid such
pairings or at least recognize that
they're in such parents and I realize of
course because of the way that we're
framing things during this series
that anytime we talk about a pairing
we're really talking about
two maps
coming together forming a new and
somewhat independent map that represents
the relationship
I have to assume that many people in the
world have maps that are very very
healthy
and they're probably even those rare
individuals that don't need to go into
those cupboards that reside within
structure of self and function of self
and do any work but I'm sort of for
those of you that are just listening
you're not watching this I'm sort of
smiling as I'm saying that because I
don't actually believe any for such
person exists I think all of us even the
healthiest among us could be even
healthier and express more generative
drive and more positivity for ourselves
and for the world will we to do that
work so it's a it's a lifelong endpoint
to that yeah that's beautiful we can do
that forever as long as we're here
and you should yeah I do believe right
which is yes one of the reasons for
having this discussion exactly
nonetheless I I have to imagine that
there are also a lot of people out there
perhaps most people who
still have a lot of work to do and those
words a lot perhaps are in bold-faced
capital underline highlighted letters
right right
and as a consequence we see
relationships in the world that are not
healthy
what are some of those common unhealthy
pairings I think it's worth spending at
least a little bit of time on this yeah
yeah sure as we talk about this I think
that we should make a sort of somewhat
simplified but hopefully helpful
distinction right so there are people
who are coming at coupling from
primarily Health right and again this
isn't to criticize people who aren't
coming at it from primarily Health right
we we all want to get to where we're
coming at anything and everything from
primarily health and there a lot of the
problems are those simple things like
wow I can't believe it didn't work out I
play the trumpet and he plays the
clarinet it's like no that wasn't a real
set of factors that's why it didn't work
out like it's more in that realm it's
not always just happen like that kind of
stuff is a big factor right when we look
in the other realm where where there's a
significantly problematic
mental health issues right which which
people come by honestly but need to face
if life is going to get better right
there are two common paradigms there now
again there are way more than two ways
this can happen but I I'm gonna
highlight too that we see a lot and
maybe more than anything else in the in
the clinical setting so the first gets
called
repetition compulsion right but don't be
very very clear I do not believe that
there is any such thing as a repetition
compulsion a compulsion is something
that one cannot control right what's
going on inside the person is very very
complicated when they're making
decisions that lead to repeating a cycle
and those are things that can change
right and do not have to be compulsive
so people are often struck by why a
person is in the same bad relationship
seemingly that they have always been in
but with a different name on the other
person right I mean people will say this
like it's that person's fourth abusive
relationship in a row and it seems to be
it's just the same person with a
different name like that people say that
a lot they say that about themselves
they say that about others and it's very
very baffling I mean you know people
have often been in my office very upset
about that like realizing they're
repeating and they don't know and it's
frightening and you know you can get a
lot of of fear and vulnerability from
that but there's a way of understanding
it that because are are
the limbic system right the emotional
parts of our minds don't care about the
clock in the calendar right so trauma
impacts the wig impacts the whole brain
but trauma impacts the limbic system it
creates strong negative emotion that
then stays with us regardless of time it
doesn't care about time right so imagine
now a person
gets in a relationship
and the relationship starts to become
abusive
right
I mean it's easy to say that and then
move on to something else
what's that like for that person what
does that feel like when that person who
they may have seen as a protector a
friend right is now
cursing at them denigrating them pushing
them hitting them I mean it's terrifying
it's horrible right so it is a deep
impact a traumatic impact on the person
and a lot of the time most of the time
like all trauma it triggers shame I said
trauma triggers shame in us if the
trauma is strong enough it changes us as
we move forward in the world and then we
are different in a way that makes the
past very immediate in the present
so what the person then is trying to do
and there's been a lot that thought
about this over the years in the fields
trying to understand this and I think in
many ways doing a good job of
understanding this that the quote
unquote repetition compulsion is the the
drive and I don't mean drive like we're
saying there's a push inside the person
to try and make that right right with
the idea that if that person can be in
that situation again right and I don't
mean in the exact situation when someone
raises a hand to them but they can
navigate a relationship because like
they thought it was a good idea the
first time so they don't want to feel
like that was a very bad idea so I'm
going to make it right and then I'm
going to be okay and I'm going to be
whole right because the person is driven
by fear and vulnerability and The Shame
of the trauma right so then they're
trying to make it right because because
the limbic system doesn't care about the
clock or the calendar if you can make it
right now you make it right in the past
right because that system doesn't care
about the past it's driven by trauma so
then the person's trying to figure out
something that is different they're
trying to choose that person behave in
the relationship they're trying to make
things different but they've selected
for a dramatically High pre-test
probability of the same thing happening
again which is why you know if I could
count the number of times that someone
has said to me
oh you're not going to help me
especially at the beginning of therapy
there's no way you can help me right my
last five relationships were totally
terrible like I there's no way there's
no hope right people have said that to
me someone has the last three the last
five the last nine and I will say back
if you tell me seven different stories
of relationships with seven pretty
different people several different
relationships as they evolved and the
same really bad outcome I'll agree with
you
but you're not going to tell me that and
that's why there's hope
and no one has ever told me seven
different stories I feel like wow you
you just can't do it right no and again
even if there were seven you know I'm
saying same thing for exaggeration right
but there are but there aren't right is
what is it it's the same thing seven
times
that's what it is because the person is
repeating and if they can understand the
what and the why why are they selecting
how are they selecting someone what's
going on inside of them we go back to
the structure of self the function of
self we address what is there then that
absolutely can change and then what will
we talk about is that person then goes
out to find another relationship even if
they said they never never would again
like now they're making the decision to
go out is to say what relationship are
you looking for you're second
you're the first one seven times no harm
no foul but you can navigate the second
because
they're in a different place they're
coming through agency and gratitude
instead of denigrating themselves if
you're what's wrong with me what's wrong
with everybody else
I'm here right even though like some bad
things have happened to me look at what
I can bring myself to bear I can go out
there and try and find someone I can see
with Clear Vision now there's agency
there's gratitude and then that person
can go out and find relationship number
two that's a really good one
in the example you gave it's very
powerful and also very extreme you know
an abusive relationship where someone is
you know sadly getting hit or you know
screamed at you know
um oftentimes it seems people end up in
repeated unsuccessful pairings meaning
unhappy pairings of
um maybe someone who's like very
strongly assertive maybe we would say
has a strong aggressive Drive some
people might even call them a narcissist
that phrase is thrown around a lot these
days I mean narcissists gaslighting like
projection these phrases are thrown
around all the time I think with uh
frankly very little understanding or of
what they actually mean unless they're
coming from a qualified clinician
is it the case that you know somewhat
passive or submissive people
are drawn to narcissists or narcissists
drawn to submissive people I think these
questions ring in a lot of people's
minds if I could clarify something that
I think I maybe could have said in a
clearer way you pointed out that the
example I gave was it was a very strong
one or an extreme one right so
as a physician I think I naturally
gravitate to the extreme circumstances
because they're the ones that bring the
greatest risk right but we're we are
talking to people in those settings
right but but most people are not in
those extreme settings right but that
extreme serves as a model for how things
that are less extreme can happen so when
I think right we're sitting here talking
to everyone across the Spectrum and most
relationships that are not going well
thank goodness are not going to be that
extreme with the repeated patterns
aren't going to be that extreme
but it's just as important to pay
attention to a pattern where one person
really is sort of more deferential than
they would like to be to the other than
is comfortable to them and they're
seeking someone ultimately who's just a
little bit more assertive and you know
that's not some disaster but it cannot
go well over time where that person
slowly gives up say more and more of
themselves and and there can be that
repeated pattern you hear people say
yeah it was a pretty good or pretty
equal at the beginning but then you know
I just had like less and less of a say
or every you know or you know then more
and more like I just became the whole
relationship right so it's no less
important when it's less dramatic right
because the relationship still goes in
the wrong way when it's more dramatic
there's more risk of course but most
people are going to be in the less
dramatic but but ju but super important
category and I think it's important to
to point that to point that out too
how much of what we're talking about is
nested on people's deep perhaps
understandable desire to just make sure
that the other person doesn't leave
I mean I can't tell you how many times
I've heard about or observed
relationships that from the outside it
seemed really unhealthy
but
it also occurred to me that people are
doing things on both sides of the
relationship that ensure that the other
person doesn't leave so I'm not talking
about a physical trapping of someone in
the environment I'm actually talking
about the opposite I'm talking about
somebody going against their better
judgment right and doing things for the
other person or against themselves or
both
perhaps even in the context of what
looks like healthy family like doing an
excessive amount of of
raising of children or excessive amount
of work uh to support the family
simply to ensure that the other person
doesn't leave right right here again we
can look across the Spectrum right so
before this you had talked about
relationships that can be very unhealthy
like a narcissistic person and how can
those relationships develop it's
important that we we touch on that in
the context of this because that's sort
of the extreme example so people who are
narcissistic meaning a narcissistic
character structure now we're getting
into the realm of significant
psychiatric problems and people who are
narcissistic are exploitive right
they're a bottomless pit of need arising
from vulnerability and yes they can be
helped and if someone out there thinks
I'm narcissistic then I'm not trying to
be negative or mean like you can get
help and you can be better that's the
whole point of what you and I are
talking about here right so people can
change but but someone who's coming at
the world through a narcissistic
character structure is exploitative of
the other and then can say survey a room
and find that person who's had trauma
such that that person is going to be
desperate not to leave a relationship
and then they can explain that person
and often behave in awful ways and the
other person won't leave now I'm giving
an example it's not the case that K that
way every you know every single time but
that's the dominant that's the dominant
picture if you have a narcissistic
person and who is that person more
likely to pair with and then you sense
the vulnerability the the desire for the
other person not to leave so and that
person would have to have then
significant problems in themselves like
potentially instead of a pathological
level of narcissism a pathological level
of dependence for example so we're in
the realm then of of real problems and
again real problems can be treated and
real problems can be improved and that's
why we have clinical care but it can
also serve as a model for seeing the
ways that are that are less dramatic
right so so there are many people who
through the desire for the other person
not to leave and we could call that
attachment insecurity right and and
maybe if we leave away the stereotype
version of it right the person doesn't
feel securely attached to the other
person right and and somewhere inside of
them they've learned that if they're
more pleasing right if they give up
little parts of themselves that person
won't leave right it might be because
that's why their mother didn't leave
their father when they think about it it
might be that's why their father left
their mother because their mother
wouldn't do that right whatever it may
be or it may be their own prior life
experience or who knows something they
read but forgot I mean usually it's
something more Salient not always but
they've internalized something that
leads to a compromise of the self now
again all that that's not what
attachment insecurity is Right
attachment insecurity is just feeling
some insecurity about the attachment so
for example I feel attachment and
security about just about everything
right I've had the experience of of
sudden
very painful losses happening right so I
have attachment and Security in the
sense that I'm worried right I get
anxious about like people going away and
and I can you know want to Over Control
like but I recognize this inside myself
I try and do my best to say look I don't
want that to make me unhealthy I want to
recognize it I want to find some happy
medium where I honor that in me but
don't get carried away with it to the
point where I try and over control and
then I push my relationships away right
so I say that because there's such a
contrast between that kind of attachment
and security which can involve Over
Control right and the kind of attachment
insecurity that can involve compromise
of the self so and we want to be very
very careful like we want to be careful
like what is a trauma Bond and what does
it mean we want to be careful what is
attachment in security and what does it
mean a certain kind of attachment and
security can lead a person to make
Progressive compromises of self that are
not good and healthy for them I'm
curious about some of these healthy
relationships from the other side
meaning from the side of the person who
is
let's hope not but in some cases
exploited or who's being taken advantage
of or in this scenario of a narcissistic
person or an abusive person is the one
who's taking the abuse
often it seems the victim in that
scenario will be truly stuck in that
situation they can't leave for financial
reasons or kids or their own internal
workings their psychological Machinery
has them locked into that in some way
and it's that Locked In by psychological
Machinery that I'm interested in and I
think a lot of people are interested in
because
from the outside we just look at that
and say you know why doesn't
the person leave why don't they just
leave but clearly there's something
about that situation that
quote unquote works for them it might
works for them I don't mean that it's
adaptive clearly it's maladaptive but
that works for them the possibility I
raised earlier perhaps is relevant here
you know maybe it works for them because
they know that the narcissist gets some
sort of internal reward for engaging
this kind of dynamic and therefore won't
leave and the other person not leaving
is of more value to them than feeling
safe even right so it's a trading one
form of safety for another or perhaps
the the victim as we're calling them in
this scenario is somebody who you know
feels a great sense of reward by serving
somebody more powerful than them this
raises all sorts of interesting
questions perhaps about power dynamics
as well which I certainly have questions
about but what are some examples of the
internal workings of such a person
that reside within those bins of
structure of self or function of self
that would put someone into that sort of
situation and lead them to stay in that
kind of situation yeah well any
situation like that if it's as you say
working for a person which at times you
know we see that from the outside
because like things continue to go along
and things continue to go forward but it
that only works for someone if they
don't have the understanding the
empowerment that we would wish for
anyone and everyone to have so what is
going on inside leads that person to
feel a sense of uh an inability to
change you know whether they can't see
their way out of it or they they kind of
could but could never navigate to it and
there's there's a problem there if
that's working for someone right because
we're talking about something that's
exploitive right that's abusive
regardless of how it's abusive and I
think I believe that can only happen in
the context of being demoralized right
or the circumstances of being so
disempowered right you know if someone
just can't go 10 feet from home like
there are situations of
um outrageous amounts of Oppression
right of a person where where the person
just cannot choose differently and
there's situations where where we as
stewards of all of us where the
government May intervene for example
ideally right that someone would come in
and help that person but barring that
kind of outlier a person would only be
in that situation in the context of
being demoralized and that
demoralization would come from too low a
drive for assertion being proactive
aggression right that that drive its
realization is too low and if we give
people the understanding and we give
them the help the means they don't have
to stay in abusive situations like we
see this in situations where our society
will intervene or is someone helpful
intervenes some person or entity will
intervene and help a person help that
person to understand
what's going on inside of them that
leads them to feel that things can't be
better they can't do better or that
they're not worth better or whatever
that may be and help them to find the
empowerment to then navigate themselves
out of the situation and and here again
I think it's not just agency but it's
agency plus gratitude right including
gratitude for having a self that could
leave a situation when people are in
situations like that
you know we talk about people as beaten
down you know it's it's it's a way to
kind of capture like what I think that
feels like and how much suffering there
is in those situations to to to to be in
that place and to not have the agency to
get out of it then the person is not
feeling a sense of gratitude for self
right they feel so bad about self that
there's nothing to be grateful for right
and there is so much to be grateful for
right I mean we could go through any
person in a situation like that and we
could list wonderful things about that
person adaptive things about that person
kind things about that person diligent
things there are things like that in
every person but if the person can't
see that they can't attach to that they
can't have the agency and gratitude then
they stay in a situation that is really
defined by the the agency and gratitude
and therefore that aggressive assertion
proactive Drive being expressed at such
a low level
I can see how a healthy relationship
could exist in relative isolation you
know not complete isolation you know and
here again I'm referring to or thinking
about a romantic relationship I can see
how a healthy romantic relationship
could exist in relative isolation you
know a few friends uh some contact with
family members or in great connectivity
with friends and family and neighbors
Etc
and still be a really great romantic
relationship
I can also see how the sorts of
relationships that we happen to be
focusing on at this moment which are
this unhealthy Dynamics
are made far worse by lack of
connectivity to Outsiders in fact uh
previous guests on this podcast was
David boss who's a professor of
evolutionary psychology down at the
University of Texas Austin and he talked
about some of his research into the dark
Triad these are narcissistic
Machiavellian sometimes also sociopathic
individuals and how that plays out in
romantic relationships and it's a
terrible thing but in an important thing
to understand
um given the unfortunate frequency that
that occurs but one of the things that I
remember so clearly from that discussion
with uh David Buss was that even when
there isn't sociopathy or a strong
desire to destroy the other that in
these sorts of relationships there's
often an attempt to isolate the person
um you know first by isolating them from
their family also from friends and
co-workers but all with the goal of
convincing that person that no one else
would want them as a way to make them
quote-unquote voluntary early stay in
other words to undermine their their
sense of safety to ramp up their sense
of anxiety except in the presence of
that individual
um and you know I'm remembering that now
because
um you know as we're talking about why
wouldn't somebody just leave why
wouldn't they just tap into that agency
and gratitude uh it's clear that the the
oppressor in this kind of relationship
um has a real incentive to try and
undermine agency and gratitude because
of course with those they would be
revealed for what they are and the
person would feel unable to leave taking
us back once again to the critical need
to cultivate agency and gratitude not
just in unhealthy but um certainly in
healthy relationships right I mean I
think the the principle here is that
Darkness always favors the oppressor
so the oppressor wishes for Darkness
so you want to isolate that person right
because when people see that things are
better for someone else they realize
things can be better
right when people are told by someone
that they're worthwhile or they're funny
or they're pretty or they're smart or
whatever the case may be they may take
that inside right you know they may take
inside oh maybe I am you know I'm
handsome and smart maybe or they start
thinking about that they're very basic
concepts that that allow a person to
entertain new
um ways to look at themselves right so
the person who's oppressing wants that
person to live in darkness they don't
want them to see that there can be
better they don't want them to be
directly told that they're better than
how things are and that same Darkness on
the outside say the lights are out
around the relationship is the goal of
the oppressor on the inside now again
the oppressor may know this and be doing
it consciously but often this gets
played out in unconscious ways like the
constant denigration of someone a person
isn't saying inside gosh I'm trying to
reduce their their agency their
aggressive Drive really down to zero
right but that's what they're doing
somewhere inside there's a knowing of
that even if it's an unconscious knowing
and then what the the impact of that
kind of abuse over time is a lower and
lower and lower ability to bring oneself
to Bear less proactive aggressive
assertive lower sense of agency and
gratitude that's really the definition
of being demoralized right and and that
kind of abuse is always promoting
demoralization because demoralization is
the darkness on the inside right just as
Envy is too right demoralization is a
form of Darkness on the inside Envy is
no less dark Envy may be a lot more
active right but in in both cases
there's no knowledge there's no growth
there's no wisdom there's no learning
right so they're the states of darkness
and and what can happen in a way that's
really so tragic to think about is you
often can have an abuser an oppressor
who who is living in total darkness
Inside by living through the lens of
envy and then you can have a person who
is being oppressed who is being
exploited who is living in darkness but
they're living in the darkness of
demoralization and no that's a very sad
thing to say to imagine and it's been a
very very sad thing to see right because
if you do clinical Psychiatry if we're
long enough you see a lot of this and it
doesn't have to be this way now even the
people who are oppressing
have it within them the majority of time
to make things better and we do see that
I took care of a man a long time ago who
had been terribly abusive to his family
and it was always unclear to me it
happened years before that that like
he just understood and again I never
understood like what happened that that
he he got it and the man really made
change like again I don't know what the
circumstance was that made that
motivation to him but he went back and
looked at himself and he went back and
looked at how his father oppressed and
terrorized the family and how he just
did it with automatically right because
what was rooted in his own fear of
vulnerability and he's going to lose his
family and not be a man anymore unless
he oppresses them like he recognized all
of it in him and he had changed it so
dramatically he had removed himself from
the family system and when I got to know
him it was years later and he was
reintegrating back in to the system
because there had been such prolonged
change and he had communicated to the
family his understanding of self so so
it's not impossible even someone who is
abusing oppressing coming through a
narcissistic character structure right
there's no therapeutic nihilism here
right things can change and things can
change in the oppressor which isn't
excusing that right I mean a person
who's doing things is morally culpable
right they often a criminally legally
culpable so that is all true just as the
ability to change is true and then the
person we think about more commonly in
this situation of course is the person
who's being oppressed and there can be
change there too but a problem is how
hard it can be that the impact of the
isolation right and also the dearth of
resources to really help people it's an
actual true story of a woman who I
believed with all my heart could get out
of the cyclic abusive situation she was
in if she had a carburetor
it's a carburetor right she had a car
the car didn't function she had a place
to go right that where others wouldn't
know that that she was there and the
problem was just a few hundred dollars
to change the carburetor but it's like
there's no place to go there's no
resources and we as a society don't help
people not maybe that someone helped
that woman and got her a carburetor and
she drove away right but it shows how we
can bring ourselves to bear as a society
to offer People Help which sometimes is
like the lifeline the person needs and
you know maybe that person you know
really needs a safe house or something
very dramatic or they need a carburetor
to get away from being terrorized but a
lot of times it's just Community Support
structures right good structures around
people in community communities that can
offer them support in situations that
may be less dramatic opportunities for
interconnection which sometimes people
can find through social venues or
through religiously Affiliated venues
but the idea idea that Community Support
Systems on all levels make a huge
difference that's how there's another
level right beyond the relationship
right it's the society it's the culture
right and that's how we on that next
level of emergence beyond the individual
relationships can foster goodness can
foster Health in each and every one of
us
how do some of these same Dynamics play
out in non-romantic relationships so for
instance in the workplace
I was weaned in academic Laboratories so
what's most familiar to me are gosh
unfortunately numerous examples where
people working in Laboratories not the
same as mine because I've been very
fortunate to have amazing benevolent
mentors quirky and outrageous at times
but benevolent nonetheless but others
around me have been in Laboratories
where for instance the the workload was
just ridiculously high like the demand
far exceeded what any person could do
and if somebody had God forbid a cold or
children like it was near impossible to
Impossible that they could meet the
standard there or
uh stress Dynamics you know it's a
pressure cooker dynamics that um made it
well anyone would call a toxic
environment you see this also in law
firms you see it in companies you see it
in families you see it in Friendship
circles right I mean how many movies are
about
um teens uh oppressing one another
through bullying and ridicule and
um and practical jokes that are anything
but funny right that are downright
destructive okay and on and on
and so often the victims in these cases
if it's not a Hollywood movie
um feel as if that's their only choice
because
um to leave is to essentially have no
other options right it's not that that's
the only option is to stay it's that to
leave is essentially to leave science
um because these people in positions of
power have the louder voice they have
the megaphone they write the letter as a
recommendation the law firms people talk
uh in as I you know kind of spool this
out in a long-form question I'm
realizing I can't think of a single
exception like as long as there are
going to be people interacting and
people talking about their interactions
and people in positions of power
this sort of dynamic is going to take
place right absolutely anytime you have
a closed system without accountability
you're just rolling the dice for that
kind of Oppression right we need
accountability you know think about
theoretically what should have happened
there right there should be higher order
accountability right whether it's in a
company or a university or wherever it
may be there should be higher order
accountability that is reasonable and
rational so it's not then acting in a
top-down way that would be over
controlling all right telling you
exactly what you can and can't say or
what you can and can't do and sometimes
there's too much rigidity that can be
enacted top down but the problem runs
both ways if there's no accountability
from the bottom up then that person is
just simply stuck right why because the
system we've put into place has failed
right and this is where we're talking
now about not just individual
relationships with two people
relationships but now we start talking
about systems of people and systems of
people are another level of emergence
with with a personality so to speak an
environment all their own you can know
everything there is to know about each
person in the system you don't know
about the system but what you do know is
that accountability is necessary I mean
probably if we added up all the examples
in history you know we'd have to talk
about them over a thousand years right I
mean how many examples do we have that
close systems without accountability are
just rolling the dice they breed
oppression you know this is this is true
and I've been at several different
places so I I'm not trying to implicate
this any one place versus another but I
was part of a medical treatment team so
this is a hierarchical medical treatment
team of maybe seven people give or take
one depending upon circumstances where
there was physical abuse going on in the
treatment team
this is true and I'm not
I'm not saying this in some exaggerated
manner where somebody brushed up too
close to someone and they slipped no
hurting someone on the treatment team
right two different people who are being
hurt by someone senior so so this is is
it a major university in a clinical
setting right and it's not again that's
not the it's not like that's the be-all
and end all but you think about the
alleged the sophistication of the people
in the system the alleged empowerment of
the people in the situation which did
not put a stop to that so we need to
have accountability the accountability
has to be reasonable it doesn't mean
over control but it doesn't mean under
control either and if that person is
being overworked as you described with
no way of winning or harmed on a you
know on a medical team and there's no
way that that person can change that the
system has failed that person and failed
them dramatically and guess who suffers
everyone does right that person suffers
right and the science that's being done
or the medical care that's being
provided is important to all of us
anyone could be the patient who who is
being taken care of by the team where
one person is hurting a couple of the
others you think that Medical Care is
going to be optimized right is the
science going to be optimized that we're
utilizing to try and make our Our Lives
better live longer be in less pain you
know what's happening there is envy that
person who's oppressing other people is
driven by Envy whether it's a
narcissistic character structure that
acts almost exclusively through Envy or
it's envy that is in this person's life
in this way or not another way does it
matter right what's going on there is
envy and envy is nothing but destructive
right the generative Drive is nothing
but productive Envy is nothing but
destructive could you remind for people
that perhaps may not have heard episodes
one and two yet that Envy is perhaps not
just a desire to be like somebody else
that Envy in the context that we're
discussing here is is something
um quite possibly different right and
there's a varying lexicon which is why
it is important to Define it because I
think people learn it in different ways
I've heard it talked about in different
ways so so to Define that
there's a difference between jealousy
and envy and again we could choose
different words but this is the way I
learned it that's been most impactful
where jealousy is is benign right it's
the idea that if I see that you have
something that I don't then I think oh
well maybe I could work harder and get
that thing right or if I can't have that
thing like maybe it's a person is
younger right okay I can't make myself
younger and I can think okay like you
know through a lens of gratitude was is
that the only thing about me right I
can't think of anything good about
myself right other than maybe I could be
younger I mean if if you come at that
through the lens of Health it's like
it's okay right it can serve to motivate
people to like try harder work harder
take a look at themselves and be more
accepting of who who they are and what
their circumstances in life and and what
kind of control they can uh enact and
what kind they can't it's okay right
Envy is different right Envy
comes at that problem from the
perspective that bringing down the other
person right is just as effective as
bringing up the self that's why Envy is
destructive so someone who might see
another person and they Envy them their
youth right they Envy they want that and
they want to bring that person down
right because I can't make myself
younger but then there is I can't make
that person older either but they can do
other things to them right they can
sexually harass them maybe they can make
terrible jokes that are really insulting
and humiliating maybe right there are
all sorts of things a person can do to
bring down someone else the an action of
Envy is destructive and and I I truly
believe this that people who who come at
the world very strongly through Envy by
and large and narcissistic character
structure this is a small percentage of
the population but that small percentage
does most of the damage on earth right
it's a strong thing to say but when I
think about you know studying political
science and thinking about history and
learning medicine and learning about
Psychiatry and sociology and really
trying to look at the world and and and
thinking what what drives a person on a
medical team who's gotten to be a senior
physician to physically hurt doctors
lower on the hierarchy Envy right that
person feels terrible about themselves
and is being destructive to those people
same thing that's the same thing is at
work in the lab the same thing is at
work when people start wars of
Destruction that just simply harm other
people and we can see no other sense of
it that from the individual
setting all the way up to the world
setting we see the destruction of envy
and we also see it inside of us because
a person who's enacting Envy in the
world around them is never have there's
no chance of happiness that hence the
the idea of a bottomless pit right
whatever you get let's say an envious
person who wants more money I want to
have more money than anybody right I
want everyone to have less money than me
right so then they come at the world
through the lens of greed when they get
more money how long does that make them
happy right this doesn't mean money is
bad or having money is bad it just means
if you're coming at the world through
the lens of Envy right and that lens is
specifically focused on money then
you'll be a greedy person who is Never
Satisfied even if you have 10 trillion
dollars right so it's never good it
takes away from that person any
possibility of happiness and if you see
people work with people with a
narcissistic character structure there
can be a sense of a very brief happiness
in the moment like I'm happy because I
realize I have something someone else
doesn't I'm happy because I'm thinking
of myself and even though I feel very
insecure and vulnerable inside I have a
whole set of defense mechanisms that let
me turn those tables around and and then
feel good about myself in a way that
places Me Above others whatever is going
on in that person it may bring some very
brief gratification in the moment but
that's not happiness hence the need for
the gratification over and over and over
again narcissistic people are the least
secure most different people on Earth
they just have a phenomenally healthy
defensive structure that comes about in
order to try and protect them that leads
them to go to the opposite some of
what's called a reaction formation going
to the very opposite denial avoidance
rationalization projection very
unhealthy defenses that then leads that
person to protect themselves from any
help while they are frantically trying
to gain some goodness that makes them
feel good for a split second and then
disappears forever hence the tremendous
predilection for Destruction
how do you and how should we think about
power dynamics in relationships and
perhaps starting with romantic
relationships I've heard it said before
that there's always power dynamics in
relationships of all kinds I don't know
if that's true or not but I've heard
that
and I've also heard that that's
particularly Salient in romantic
relationships independent of whether or
not it's a homosexual or heterosexual
relationship that there's always to some
extent or another one leader and one
follower uh this is a uh interesting
perhaps a controversial idea but I've
heard it enough times that I want to
know more about it sure so power
dynamics of course very important
but also something we tend to be so over
reductionist about I mean this idea
thing about that there's always a leader
and there's always a follower every
single relationship right that's true on
balance like we tend to be so
reductionist and then what we do is we
miss the real power dynamics that are
going on just like I said in a previous
episode that I think my math minor has
helped me the most for like all of life
right I think a power dynamics course
that I took as an undergraduate in
political science has helped me the most
as a psychiatrist took it long before
medical school because that class taught
me so much about power dynamics I
thought it was going to be about overt
power who has power over whom and tells
whom to do what right but what I learned
is so much of power dynamics are covert
they're under the surface for example
they're the things that are not said
something that was called at the time at
least the issue of the non-issue right
where there's an issue between two
people like this person never takes out
the garbage that person always takes off
the garbage that person is resentful
about it both of them know but the
person who always does it can't say so
because if they say so the first person
will punish them in some other way right
by not taking out the garbage then the
place smells that person goes to work
and the person who's at home has to take
it out right that's one example of the
issue of the non-issue other examples
are where someone is looking and smiling
and and being really nice to someone who
they know is going to physically harm
them if they bring to light that they're
actually not happy and don't feel good
about that person right so from the
dramatic to the non-dramatic unstated
power dynamics are going on all over the
place and they're in every single
relationship I mean unless a person is
in a relationship with someone else and
they're both comatose
no I guess only one of them has to be
comatose right there are power dynamics
going on but again it doesn't mean that
they're unhealthy right because there
are always power dynamics so then what
are we looking for and again there are a
lot of things we could look for but we
could talk about really two primary
things one is look for the non-obvious
and two is the give and take
so the first Even in our own
relationships because it's it's
interesting how many people will say
talk about the power dynamics in their
relationship they're not always saying
here are the power dynamics in my
relationship but they're telling me
about them and they're telling me about
the things that are overt right now
somewhere inside of them they know that
you know they can't really raise issue a
b or c or there'll be some retribution
whether it's small or large or they
might even know everything's okay and
that person is happy but they know I'm
not giving them room to say that they're
not happy and that could just mean you
know if they say they're not happy then
um I'll come home a couple hours late
the next day and that person will feel
some attachment insecurity because of
that and you know there are all sorts of
ways this can play out but since so much
of power dynamics are are unstated or
covert kind of like the iceberg of
conscious and unconscious there's an
iceberg of power dynamics so to think
about including in one's own
relationships whether it's a neighbor
it's a friend it's a work relationship
or most charged it's Roman chance what's
really going on between us
right what's really going on between us
I'm not looking to
tell myself lies right I know that I may
not be able to understand all of it but
let me stop and think about it and
people if you ask people to stop and do
that they can say
yeah it's really not okay or you know
because sometimes they don't know that
it's there or they don't want to know
that it's there and and the therapy work
is trying to guide them to there's an
immense power disparity maybe in the
relationship when they're presenting no
everything is equal to Goose a good
supportive relationship you hear that a
lot and of course it's not always that
there's something bad under the surface
but a lot of times there is and even
something mildly bad is not okay and can
cause problems and sometimes there's
something very bad so look for the
non-obvious and then the second is that
give and take is a is a very good sign
of Health is a very good sign of health
so if a person can kind of see that
there's give and take and it might be
about something as simple as like who
chooses where we go to dinner okay you
know sometimes one sometimes the other
depends who has a stronger feeling or it
may be that person always decides where
we go to dinner but the other person's
okay with it right and that person
always decides what movie they want
you're the other person right so the
idea that there's given take and then in
periods of time where where one person
may be in a more difficult Place one
person has a significant loss right or
an injury or an illness then you see
that that shifts a little bit one person
is giving more right but then ultimately
the idea is that's from the outside
right if one person is giving more to
the other there's a generosity of spirit
in both the giving and the accepting
right that leads them to then be
stronger together so even when people
say Well they're imbalances in some way
if you just look at what's going on day
to day but in a healthy relationship
with high generative Drive the periods
of imbalance strengthen the the
relationship where you see this with
friends where two people have a pretty
equal friendship and and then like one
person is something difficult happens
and the other person is there for them
what's true on the other side of that
they're better friends right and it's
also why we often want to be
interconnected when we're healthy what
if something bad happens to both of them
right it's good to be interconnected and
friends and family can be supportive to
us so so the idea that give and take is
healthy I think is is very Central so
just looking for evidence that's often
if I don't understand like what's going
on in the relationship maybe it's early
in the therapy or it's just been kind of
opaque or I can't figure it out I'm
looking for is there a give and take
because then I'm going to think okay
more likely than not things you're
healthy if I see an imbalance whether
the person knows it or not I'm thinking
more likely than not it's unhealthy and
then they're just Clues along the
pathway of of of my efforts to
understand
the non-obvious piece is really
intriguing as is the give and take and I
really appreciate that you brought up
the give and take because that's a a
very concrete place that we can all look
and ask ourselves you know even if
people aren't in romantic relationships
like you know what is the give and take
in a given friendship
um and as you mentioned earlier it
doesn't have to be scripted one for one
one for one
um maybe it bounces out over time or
maybe it doesn't I mean I've had
friendships that have lasted many
decades even where I can honestly say
I'm always the person to reach out to
the other person but when they connect
they connect with such a depth of
attention that I don't feel any
deprivation whatsoever in fact I don't
think I've ever considered that I'm the
person that always reaches out until
today and so it doesn't bother me
whatsoever I feel infinitely rewarded in
the relationship like it's generative
right it feels generative right it
doesn't have to be equal however one
wants to Define equal but it has to be
mutual like you're getting you know
you're feeling goodness from the
relationship so is the other person okay
that's good that's coming from that high
generative place and when we really
let's say we push that concept forward
to where we want to be living not some
pie in the sky right but agency and
gratitude as verbs the generative Drive
is very strongly expressed and the other
drives are subserving the generative
drive then we get to the place where we
really see it is true that it is better
to give than to receive
the happiest people I see are the people
who are giving now of course it feels
great to receive right but it feels
better to give because there's a
goodness in the self in the giving and I
remember seeing this as a child and
being too young to understand it but as
a little kid I liked getting things
right and as a little kid I liked
getting things more than I liked giving
like that's okay when you're a little
kid but what I did observe is that my
maternal grandmother who is very sweet
and loving and and caring she loved
giving right you give her presence and
we did and she liked she really liked
getting presents she loved giving right
there was an excess of goodness and then
as I got older and I learned more like
who she had been in the community and
how she had been to people and and I I
could see and now through the lens that
there was such goodness in her I think
she's you know for me she's The Shining
model of goodness that I internalize as
I aspire to be better so then I think I
want to be like that I am more
generative as I try and think more about
giving than receiving it's I'm not
trying to say I'm some Noble person or
I'm being ascetic I'm saying that's a
good way for us all to feel right or
someone a very very successful person
that that I uh consult with is in my
life right who's who talked about how he
always makes inside of himself the best
understanding of what's going on between
him and another person whether it's a
very big Financial deal or it's about
power or it's personal and then gives a
little bit always where have we ended up
let me give a little bit right and and
there's a person he's very very
successful very very happy right but
again I would argue
the goodness in him
is why he's successful and happy it's
not that he's successful and therefore
he's happy right it's what's inside of
him that Fosters both of those good
things and he could be just as happy
without the big success maybe wouldn't
maybe he wasn't uh minded to do that and
and he grows a nice Garden like he could
be equally happy but the point is the
goodness in self
to to be able to do that right to feel
good about doing that I feel better
about giving that than I would have
receiving that that's pretty Stark right
something given to the other that I
would have gotten right now and we're in
maybe a negotiation to give it feels
better than to have it
I'm sure there are many people thinking
about individuals who are highly
successful who are not givers who are
takers
I do think those examples of takers as
I'm calling them grab a lot of attention
but I know at least within science and
the other domains of life I've been in
that there are far more
successful people who are also givers
even to a great extent and of course
that doesn't mean that they're giving to
the point of um an inability to give
further or to take care of themselves
the giving is part of taking care of
themselves but it's part of this
generative cycle it's not one thing it's
not a Tit for Tat it's a it's it's part
of something that makes them feel good
makes others feel good
um it's it's sort of anti-transactional
and as we're talking about the self and
interrelations between selves in these
different relationship contexts today
this word transactional keeps coming to
mind
um and what I'm so aware of as you're
describing what healthy selves and
healthy relationships look like is that
it runs counter to pretty much
everything that I've heard and that we
hear in the world about relationships
and about the relationship to self
meaning it's not transactional it's
really about a cycle and we're using
this word General
in its specific context today so I don't
want to rob that word for uh for a
different purpose but I'm imagining a
sort of upward spiral um in my mind or
perhaps something that's that's really
like the a circle of life that just
keeps growing bigger and bigger and
bigger
um
maybe we could talk a little bit about
this notion of relationships being
transactional I mean it's such a loaded
word
um but I have a close friend who's
married with more than a few children
who you know told me the other day
um you know I realized that it's all
kind of transactional like they're
extracting for me and I'm extracting
from them and it's benevolent because
it's all good and and I I thought wow
this is really this is really Dreadful
you know like no one wants to think that
the closest relationships in their lives
are transactional and he was coming to
that conclusion I I disagreed with him
and I don't know where that all sits for
him right now but maybe we could talk
about the the transactional versus
non-transactional aspects of
relationship because
um we all want things that's perfectly
healthy I believe
um we all experience disappointment and
pleasure and relief and
um sometimes major disappointment
pleasure relief Etc but what is the role
of transaction in relationships and you
know how does Psychiatry how do you and
how should we think about that well we
often get confused because there are
transactions in every relation chip but
that does not mean that every
relationship is transactional right so
if we think about what transactions are
we can think of the kind of the
stereotypical way so it can also be like
here's the transaction I'll do the
dishes and you wash the clothes right or
for instance I'll make the money and the
other person will raise the children
right right so so there are transactions
right but that does not mean that the be
all and end-all of it are sort of
hard-hearted calculated transactions and
transactions also occur in less obvious
but equally important ways right so
another way that transactions occur is
so right now I'm putting something out
there right so I'm saying something
right and then at a point I stop and I'm
waiting for you to put something out
there and then I take in what you said
and we're doing something that in that
sense is transactional I'm waiting for
you to give me something I take it in I
process it I give something back out to
you but that's not the be all and end
all all of it so there are transactions
whether it's the you know who's going to
wash the dishes who's going to do the
clothes or it's what do I put out there
that you take in and what do you put out
there that I take in that there is
something greater than something beyond
the transactional and there is some
controversy to this a thought that that
that there really are a historical
thought in the field that there are just
aggressive and pleasure drives in us and
that everything is transactional now
again we don't really have a way of
disproving that I mean there's not going
to be some equation that disproves that
but I think it's entirely disproven by
human experience and there's so many
I mean I could you know we could we
could talk about an infinite number of
resources to consider this but just
imagine the writings of Victor Frankel
and the and the writings and the
theories around human interactions and
and psychological theories that have
come of it to think that everything is
just transactional it's a denial of the
humanness in all of us that I think he
just brought to the fore so strongly but
again there could be nearly infinite
infinite resources throughout human
history that say hey we're not entirely
transactional it's not just aggression
and pleasure but there's something more
going on here there's learning that
feels good for the sake of learning
there's kindness that feels good for the
sake of kindness there's giving that
feels good because giving feels good
like this is going on in us it's going
on when we're like loving children for
example we're loving animals there's
something inside of us that's not just
transactional and that's why like I
think what we're talking about is is if
it's truth it should all hang together
right it must all hang together and and
this is why there's an us right over top
of each individual that's in a
relationship right this is why you can
know everything about me you can know
everything about you and you can know
nothing about our friendship right
absolutely nothing right because it's
something different right and if it were
all just transactional there would be
nothing different right and I think
think our experience as human beings
right I know that to be true because I
just know that I don't always feel
selfish about things right like maybe
sometimes I do and I do something nice
because it'll make me look good like
okay we're all human right but I know
that there's good feeling from others
towards me at times it's just about the
good feeling I know that there's that
from me towards others so that tells us
yes there is something other than just
the eye there is the we of dyads right
of relationships no matter whether their
work family friendship relationship and
then they're the levels beyond that that
are larger wheeze right the we of groups
so if I understand correctly it can be
the case that one person makes the
majority or all of the income for family
the other person raises the children
takes care of the majority of the home
and of course there is a transaction
there a set of transactions but that
it's in service to something larger that
really isn't transactional right I'm
just stealing your words here but um if
I were to expand on that just to make
sure I understand that the
non-transactional thing that emerges
from that is uh generative because it's
a family right it's a family that
everyone can extract growth and pleasure
and meaning from
um and just because the roles are
divided as such it doesn't necessarily
mean that the relationship is defined as
transactional in in the sense that it's
um less than it could be right right
right if you think about what's really
being transacted so say one person is
out in the world and is making an income
the other person is say taking care of
the family being taken care of the home
what's being transacted well the person
who's making the money is sharing the
money right is in that sense transacting
some of the money to the other person
like you get to have some of it too you
get to have some of the benefit from it
and the person who is at home who's
taking care of the family in the home
saying you get to have some of that too
right you get to come here the children
are taken care of right the home is
taken care of so both are transacting
something to the other right I mean
that's the truth of it right if you look
at what's really going on there one
person's getting benefit of money they
didn't earn the other person's getting
benefits they have child care they
didn't do or pay for right it's not
paying for child care they're sharing
resources right so yes that's true but
is that it I mean are these two robots
right one is the money making robot and
the other is the child care robot like
that's not what's going on right the way
we want to Envision that if we have two
healthy people with generative drives is
they love one another they're creating
something better than they could create
on their own in fact they've created
children right they've created a home
together and they're nurturing that
family together that is generative and
because it's generative it can also be
flexible so let's say the person who's
at home says I need to do some things
outside of the house right or let's say
the person who's out working thinks oh I
feel overwhelmed and I like to switch to
a better job but that job's half time
but I want to be I could be half in the
house right like this is where people
can come together right in the same way
we talked about the two and an eight on
the sex drive or sexuality scale where
people then can find compromises right
and if one really wants to stay out of
the home all the time but the person in
the home wants to leave the home well
they find a way that that works right
because they're care for one another the
generative spirit that is in them
individually and as a couple lets them
nurture that and one isn't interested in
oppressing the other I'm not going to
leave my job you stay at home or I'm
staying at home you stay out there it's
like okay let's let's think about things
let's let's communicate right that's how
the generative drive not only like makes
that awesome right like the five isn't
the compromised position between the
eight and the two the five is awesome
right here the transactional aspects are
awesome because of the generative
aspects of what comes of it far more
than either of those people could make
on their own I mean women say it's not
so obvious maybe if one makes x amount
of dollars each could make half X that's
not what we're talking about neither of
them can create that family on their own
it seems that so much of what we're
talking about relies on you know the
Hallmarks the that we always hear make
up good relationships of all kinds
romantic and otherwise like things like
communication listening generosity okay
all the stuff that we all know that we
should bring to relationship and
hopefully are getting from relationships
and that if we're not that we should
probably request from others in in you
know polite ways right can I connect I
have one word for that
kindergarten
right think about that we learned that
in kindergarten what you're describing
is so simple
right that's why it's so high up on the
this is what the geyser is pushing up
it's high up from the two pillars right
because what you're talking about is
simple generosity of spirit giving
rather than taking right being kind to
others letting things go feeling good
about yourself even if you fall down
right we learned this in kindergarten so
we must somewhere inside of us really
value it right but then we let it go we
make things overly complex and you know
this this
idea that in many ways we should go back
to kindergarten right because there's a
purity there right children in an age
where you know they can learn and then
we bring a nice kind of learning to them
and a nurturing to them and we can bring
it to ourselves too so that we simplify
that which has become overly complex
right we simplify because trauma makes
complexity having to just make one's way
in the world it is complicated right so
things that more and more complicated
and we lose the simple roots of goodness
or the goodness of Simplicity right and
we can come back to that so I I couldn't
resist when he said oh these are kind of
simple are these basic things right like
right that's the point of it because
that's where agency and gratitude and
the generative that's where they live in
the simplicity
I'm glad you mentioned kindergarten it
brought me back to
um images of kindergarten where yeah as
far as I can remember now there were all
the critical components of a great
generative environment you know adults
who really cared about us fortunately
they were snack time with oranges so
nourishing food right there was nap time
in the afternoon like these things are
all things got some exercise explorers
they could take a guinea pig home on the
weekends because they had this guinea
pig I think they actually I think there
were several guinea pigs but they kept
trying to convince us it was the same
guinea pig because they would allow one
family to take home the guinea pig each
weekend and sometimes I think it didn't
work out quite so well but anyway the
guinea pig was a pervasive feature so
you learned to take care of things and
in all seriousness now that I step back
from it there's nothing more generative
it seems than the kindergarten classroom
environment or we should say a healthy
kindergarten classroom environment it's
all about support of others and um if we
go to the pillars uh the structure of
self and the function of self I mean
surely there's a lot going on at home
too but think about like what's Salient
it's learning messages of self
um you know self-confidence like
instilling those it's behaviors that are
based on strivings and hopefulness it's
all the good things yes all the good
things and so you know as I
was thinking about communication and all
these good things that clearly
kindergarten is a wonderful template for
in all seriousness I think is an amazing
template
I'm thinking about what gets in the way
and of course trauma can get in the way
um and we should talk about that more
but it seems to me that one of the
things that gets in the way of asking
for what we want of hearing requests of
us in the way that is going to bring
about the most generative goodness is
anxiety it's like you know you're tired
from a long day and someone mentions
like you know we we have to take the
trash out you know like like I was at
work all day like
you know that kind of thing or
um earlier talking about the issue of
the non-issue in terms of power dynamics
um you know that
well let's just say I've had the
experience before in relationship of
feeling like if I make a request or I
have a quote unquote complaint about
something that the other person is going
to be so upset about the fact that they
didn't do something well that's gonna be
three days
of just like diminished happiness for
everybody so I just assumed like not
deal with it right so when we hear the
word anxiety I think we often think
about the person like quaking about you
know public speaking or like getting
um the circuits in their brain hijacked
that were only designed for
saber-toothed tigers but you know
anxiety seems to serve both a very
important functional role in Modern Life
that has nothing to do with physical
threat
but it also seems to be the feature that
if not kept in check if we can't
regulate our own anxiety
I'm realizing there's no way that we're
going to be in a position to ask for
what we need and what we want to hear
what's needed of us and what others want
in other words
anxiety seems like a major barrier to
the generative Drive
I think the place to start is if you
show me a person who has no anxiety I'll
show you a mannequin right we all have
anxiety in us remember it's just a word
right what do we what are we getting at
we're getting at a sense of tension
right or a sense of this quiet inside of
us that that we would like to solve we
would like to ease if we could right it
is not helpful or healthy if we have
very very low levels of that right
because then our strivings are certainly
going to suffer right there's not a lot
of motivation right to to go make change
in the world a change in our lives right
so if we have too little of that tension
that doesn't go well and and could that
maps to a low uh assertiveness right
aggression proactive Drive is there
other ways that can show itself but it
Maps very clearly I think to that and
that's not good for us on the other end
of the spectrum we're much more
concerned with the other end of the
spectrum because a lot of anxiety feels
very very bad and it feels very bad
right now right so our our high levels
of anxiety they narrow our cognitive
spectrum they narrow our ability to
think about what's going on around us to
think about ourselves so so the idea
with anxiety is to recognize hey we all
have it and and we can call it anxiety
we can call it tension we call whatever
we we want to but we want that to be in
in in a healthy place right which which
comes of course back to the self that if
my levels of anxiety are very high and
therefore it's causing problems in my
relationship like maybe
um I'm always asking my partner if we're
okay right that happens a lot like are
we okay are you happy right right
because there's a lot of anxiety in me
like the first place to go is to look at
myself so we could say oh I have
attachment and security that's just
stating the obvious right or sergeantra
but a very common one uh nowadays that I
think is new in the course of human
history is
um you know the the reaching the tugging
the line phenomenon you text somebody
because you're thinking about them you
don't hear back and then attention
starts to mount and then um depending on
the context you may either be concerned
about the person or even suspicious
about what the person is up to I mean
here it's very contextual right and it
depends on the history of both
individuals and that relationship but
then the person will reach back
eventually and it either will bring
relief or relief with some resent like
where were you what happened
um you know this is very very common
um so much so in fact that I've come to
learn and talking to others and this is
the the classic you know I have a friend
who but really
um others who are in the landscape of
looking for a relationship and
there are people I know well who go
through a lot of effort to set an
intermittent schedule of response like
to not give the other person in a sense
that they always respond with short
latency because indeed sometimes they
they will be able to do that and
sometimes they won't what they're
basically trying to do is make sure that
the person doesn't they're actually
trying to take care of the other person
in addition to themselves because I
think we come to expect a certain
latency of response with certain
individuals and if we don't hear back
with that particular latency of response
our own anxiety starts to pick up and it
can be quite damaging to a relationship
in particular to the generative drives
within us because in that time that
we're stressed we're not tending to
other things including things that we
could do for the relationship that we're
so worried about the famous scene in
swingers right where the person leaves a
message and then you know and lives the
whole relationship in his own mind and
breaks up with the person and they never
actually spoke right that there's the
anxiety run wild and of course I
remember that was very very popular when
that came out why because it resonated
you know with the insecurities we feel
and now with the ability to feel those
insecurities in a much more immediate
way that person didn't text me back
right there's a lot more of that inside
of us which really points to if you're
able to identify that you're that you're
anxious too anxious for Comfort which
again if one looks inside or even
listens maybe to what others have said
or reflected like there's a lot of data
especially introspection to be able to
identify that right the next question is
always why
right let's go look at that maybe that
person has been anxious their whole life
right maybe they just have run tents all
the time you know sometimes a little bit
of medicine that kind of just pulls that
down person can take that for 50 years
life is better there's no side effects
like so sometimes like that might be the
case right sometimes the person's
anxiety kind of grew throughout
childhood and maybe that's because there
were difficult things or traumatic
things that happened maybe there was
nothing like that but maybe the person
was very good at engaging in the world
and then felt more and more pressures
upon themselves and no one ever did
anything wrong and they'd only been
rewarded right but regardless look at
the anxiety in yourself go back to those
pillars right and one might discover for
example maybe the the anxiety I'm
feeling is attributable to the other
person am I feeling anxious because I'm
intimidated right am I feeling anxious
because I know that if I don't behave in
a certain way you know the next time
there's a group meeting there'll be some
snarky joke made about me so anxiety
sometimes it's the self sometimes it's
still got a lot of biological components
and sometimes he's got a lot of
psychological components sometimes both
right sometimes it's the environment
sometimes it's the other right the other
person so look at why because that's how
we learn right like what is going on
inside of me where is that level of
anxiety how does it not feel comfortable
like what actually is it how is it
changing how I'm behaving how might it
be changing how am I responding to it so
what are we doing we're going back to to
this look in those 10 cabinets and
figure out why which we can do right the
vast majority of times between ourselves
and the use of others either
professionally or non-professionally we
can go understand the anxiety or the
lack of anxiety why am I not so
motivated right I mean that's a case
with a lot of people who feel
demoralized they don't feel they can get
anywhere in the world right the world's
a bad place and you know and how are you
going to make your way in the world and
they start feeling nihilistic or you
know they feel like there's the eight
ball is against them even in a
generational capacity right and now they
feel demoralized and and the tension
inside is soothed by things so maybe
that's the person who's overusing the
thing that soothes right so they could
go look at hey like I always kind of
motivated and did well in sports or the
well in this was interested in that
right what's going on that's how a
person could identify for example being
demoralized so that process of inquiry
gives us the information that we can use
in the service of change and the change
while not achieved 100 of the time the
change for the better is predictable if
it's arising from a place of
understanding
I'm very curious about frames of Mind in
relationship in particular how being in
our own experience say
anxious because someone hasn't responded
to us and really paying attention to the
anxiety and drilling into it and asking
ourselves you know why am I anxious and
um do I deserve to be anxious is it
about me is it about them
whether or not that's a valid pursuit or
whether or not
focusing on the other person and trying
to imagine you know like what's going on
in their head that they might be doing
this or that they seem to do something
repeatedly this of course relates to
much more than just the scenario of
waiting for a text message and feeling
anxious I mean I think so much of how we
come into relationships of all kinds uh
you know romantic certainly but family
relationships or you know in and around
the tendency to switch back and forth
sometimes seemingly at random between
our own experience and what am I feeling
what am I experiencing and then thinking
about the other like what is what are
they thinking what are they experiencing
I mean this is
everything to do with human dynamics
right I I would think that it's near
impossible for the typical person
to just live life through their own uh
frame and lens and never pay attention
at all to what others might be thinking
even for instance the most exploit of
extractive narcissist sociopath
presumably is thinking about you know
who in the room is going to be their
Target because of how that person might
be feeling and of course on the
benevolent side people who want to do
um positive generative things in the
world are probably thinking about you
know who to align with
um who who has common goals that they
might want to work with or be with
romantically that could help them and
and the other person generate so so what
is this thing that we do uh you know
what is it called and and how does it
work to place ourselves in the mind of
others and what roles does it serve and
what goals does it undercut when we do
this well so I think the first thing to
say is that everything follows the same
simple pattern right so I start with
thinking about me right if I'm anxious
why am I anxious what's going on inside
of me that I think about you are you
anxious too or maybe I'm not anxious but
I notice that you are right so there's
the thought about the eye because I
can't think in a clear-headed way about
you unless I've thought about me right
because if I'm really really anxious
then how am I supposed to understand and
try and get an idea of where you're at
right so then where do we arrive we
arrive at the magic Bridge of the US
hey that's what connects us whether the
US is a friendship it's a professional
relationship it's romance right there's
the bridge of the US because it's not
just how or when am I anxious how or
when are you anxious
what are things like when we're together
right maybe that maybe I'm anxious when
we're together and what's that tension
about your anction when we're together
and you know maybe that's for reasons we
could talk about and make less maybe
there's some insecurity in one of us or
maybe the other person is behaving in a
certain way that's not making the the
second person feel good right we we can
then come together and see how does the
US impact the level of anxiety and how
do we then take away from the US being
stronger so so think about we talked
about the trauma Bond trauma Bond can be
enacted in a negative way it can be
enacted in a positive way and those two
people who can go to the museum together
who can't go to the museums separately
right they're living in the magic Bridge
of the US right they're both at the
Museum but neither can go to the museum
right neither can go to the museum but
both can go to the museum and then they
take away stronger selves from that
right that's that's a reinforcing
experience it's positive right it builds
the generative drive it builds
confidence right the person went they
were assertive and that was gratified in
a good way and they felt pleasure right
so when we look at the US it is about
the US in the moment right but it is
also about how two people are impacting
one another in the rest of their lives
and this of course this is more
important the closer the relationship
like this is very important for example
in close friendships or family
relationships and I think this is of
extreme importance in relationships
right these are the the two people who
presumably are the closest to one
another on Earth so a shared us that
that promotes understanding and bolsters
a sense of agency and gratitude and
bolsters the generative drive like
that's great for both people when
they're not in the US when one goes one
way and one goes the other because that
happens all the time in relationships
too right or go to work at different
places or you know we bolster ourselves
outside of relationships if we see what
the magic Bridge of the relationship can
be so we we can look there for problems
like why am I anxious why are you
anxious why are we anxious why are you
only anxious when we're we and not you
know we can look over all that and we
should right but we can also even more
powerfully look for the good there right
how can our shared Bond whatever it may
be be better for both of us and what's
stronger incentive could there be than
to do that in relationships right
romantic relationships the ones that are
closest to us if they're not romantic
they could be friendships whatever our
closest relationships are they're the
most important Vehicles so to speak to
better health and happiness to getting
to that place of peace and
contentment and Delight right the US is
very very powerful in fact even more
more powerful than the I and the you
when thinking about the US
and trying to understand why somebody
that we know and are in relationship
with is behaving the way they are or
might be feeling or claiming they feel
the way that they are how useful do you
think it is for us to put ourselves in
their shoes you know um you know I can
think of all sorts of ways in which this
could be beneficial I can also think of
all sorts of ways in which it would be
focusing off the self
and our own experience in ways that
um might be defensive avoidance or you
know or denial right you know I'll come
clean I mean there's been plenty of
times in relationship where I get
fixated on why someone is the way they
are behaved the way they did and um more
often than not by taking a step back and
thinking about why my reaction to that
is the way it is I don't solve the
quote-unquote problem but I get a lot
further along in terms of
um quelling my own anxiety and finding a
path forward right right right well
mentalization right which is the ability
to discern feeling States intention
States and self and others but now we're
looking for others right so the ability
to understand feeling States what's
going on inside of you intention what
are your intentions right that should
only be good
right because because if we're seeing it
through a clear lens meaning a lens
that's not biased by some problem like
like a defense mechanism of
rationalization for example or
projection right if we're seeing clearly
we're learning about the other
right and the learning is is never bad
right knowledge truth is good so if we
learn about the other by in that sense
putting ourselves in their shoes then we
gain information but it's the health in
US
that that is so crucial to what we do
with that information right so one
person can say put put themselves in the
other person's shoes and and they can
say okay that person I can see that
person's responding and they say pretty
calm pretty calm about something right
and maybe that's just a good thing maybe
there's some contention going on and
that person's maintaining their cool and
that person is going to be really
helpful in navigating an argument or a
disagreement to like some some like
really positive end point right
so if a person sees clearly like I see I
okay I see that I can see that you're
calm and I also see that you're trying
to figure things out and you the things
that you're saying are sort of positive
you're disagreeing with me but but you
don't seem to mean ill right then I can
see you know what I think your calm is
good right because I'm getting a little
bit upset and you're not so you you so I
and I see that there's a benevolence in
you so maybe you'll guide us to the
place that maybe I can't right but but
think about if there's not a clear lens
inside of me right if I have a defense
system that leads me to externalize
responsibility that leads me to project
or leads me do all sorts of things that
are not healthy now I might think well
you're calm because you just don't care
about me
right I mean so the thing with the same
exact thing right now in the example
we're giving the person in your position
is like being really benign and
benevolent but it happens all the time
where that is misconstrued so it's not
that it's not that the insight
that person is calm I see that they're
calm it's that there's a deficit in the
mentalization the person is not fully
understanding their intention right
what's coming through then gets
distorted right so we think about
defense mechanisms they can be they can
be clear they can let light through in
this beautiful way that has Fidelity or
they can be very distorting so the
thought if I'm Discerning that you are
benevolent and you you seem to be trying
to solve the problem for us but I take
in and you just don't care about me and
you're trying to put one over on me if
if I've assessed it accurately but the
but it comes on the other end in a way
that's changed right that's because
there's a lack of clarity there's
Distortion inside of me
right so so then if I'm really working
on myself I'm in the best place I can be
I'm going to be better at mentalizing
about you and me right even if I say
well we're having a disagreement I I
know I tend to get a little defensive so
I'm going to be a little biased to see
what's in you in a kind of negative way
right so what am I seeing like okay
you're pretty calm like maybe you don't
care like no I know I can think that
right but like come on you're trying you
want to solve our problem like like
imagine when that goes on inside of a
person which sometimes goes on
consciously or goes on unconsciously or
some mixture it's so powerful right the
person is aware of their own state which
helps them to be aware of the state of
the others or the other and then the
information they're getting comes
through with Fidelity and now all of a
sudden instead of maybe I'm going to
blow things up now I'm aligning with you
in solving our problem because I see
clearly about you and me and that's
going on all the time it might say well
it's complicated there's a lot of back
and forth right there are millions of
things going on every Split Second in
our unconscious mind that is throwing
all this up to the conscious mind it's
doing things rapidly that's going on all
the time in us whether we want to
acknowledge it or not and we we choose
not to acknowledge it at our own Peril
because then we're not going to those
two pillars and they're ten cupboards
we're not going to the structure of self
the function of self and what comprises
those two pillars to look for hey what's
going on right let me understand better
and even if things are going well right
we can always as you said not that long
ago we can understand ourselves better
the the stronger I am the more
generative drive there is in me the less
defensiveness the more the agency and
the Gratitude the more I'm armed for you
know whatever difficult thing comes my
way so if there's a conflict with
someone whether there should be or there
shouldn't be maybe someone's being
really aggressive and I got to kind of
say some things and try and counter that
right I'm going to be able to discern
one from another I'm going to be more
effective in both right I just myself up
for success and if I'm setting me up for
Success then I'm also setting you up for
Success if you're someone I have a
relationship with no matter what it is
and then ultimately I'm setting the Wii
right the the magical Bridge of us I'm
setting that up for Success too and
that's how you see in these levels of
emergence that you know if you
understand everything about you and
understand everything about me and and
let's say the person understands we have
a generative Drive
you don't really know what our
relationship is going to be like you
think I bet it's going to be a good one
right and then what would we then then
contribute say to a broader culture so a
group of people maybe there's 10 people
a bunch of friends getting together we
would contribute goodness at that next
level which is then the culture of the
larger group in hearing your description
of mentalization this ability for all of
us to get into the mind of another and
to try and imagine motivations and
states that would explain their behavior
right okay
yeah that seems like a natural reflex
that's that's healthy and it it seems to
surface most often in um as the
consequence of negative interactions
right you know something didn't go right
and so we kind of explore like was it
them was it me like was it something
that happened before you know what else
is going on with this person as a way to
try and arrive at some sort of hopefully
generative understanding but it seems to
me there's also great value in
mentalizing about others under
conditions in which things are going
well so that one can potentially make
things or encourage things to go even
better in future interactions right well
the first thing I would say is I think
the reflex is most often not mentalizing
that the reflexes most often not
mentalizing right because the reflexes
often come from a position of not
feeling safe
right there's some conflict I don't I
don't I don't feel good right there's
some conflict people you know we all can
get very defensive very quickly whether
we show it on the outside or we start
partitioning inside and that the
problems come not from mentalizing but
they come from not mentalizing right and
and not being aware of the difference
because then I conclude I know what's
going on in you and I don't
right because I don't know what's going
on in me right and I think you're being
aggressive really I'm feeling kind of
defensive I'm feeling vulnerable and
then I'm I'm getting aggressive right
but I can't handle that because I don't
want to be aggressive so you're
aggressive right so there's such a
difference between say coming at a
self-other conflict from the perspective
of say not mentalizing but thinking that
you are versus mentalizing if there's a
difference between is it me I know it
can't be
is it you it must be right and that's
how a lot of that goes and then of
course what's the data that's gathered
the data that's gathered supports that I
mean I think this is Wars I think have
happened you know based upon this let
alone conflicts and friendships and in
relationships the key about mentalizing
is that's not what it is mentalizing it
goes like this
is it me is it you is it us
let's figure that out let's figure it
out together right it's it's not it's
not defensive it's not aggressive it's
not projecting it's it's it's really
actually seeing and look if it's me I
want to be aware of it and say yeah like
whoa I get up on the wrong side of the
bed like let me just say I'm sorry right
or if I might say look I know that
you're being aggressive and you normally
you wouldn't be them and say like oh can
we just get away from this hit let the
person I care about calm down come back
later you know or if it's us there's
really something between us and let's
sort it out like the information that
allows the healthy right the agency and
gratitude decisions is always there
through mentalizing the danger is when
we're not mentalizing but we think we
are
got it
in keeping with thinking about others
and what's going on with them
mentalizing that is and then thinking
about what's going on with ourselves and
the exploration of the cupboards under
the pillars of structure of
self-function of self and our desire for
all that to geyser up into agency and
gratitude
one thing that we hear about so much
these days and generally I think it's
good that people are talking about them
are boundaries right you know you've
crossed my boundary or I'm setting a
boundary and uh I've certainly embedded
the the message in my head that in order
for certain relationships to be at their
most loving in my life sometimes the
boundaries require very little frequency
of communication
but that doesn't mean the relationships
aren't ongoing and uh so what are your
thoughts on boundaries and how should we
think about boundaries for sake of
healthy relationships
healthy boundaries always start inside
and then once we have them squared away
inside we can project them outward right
the same is is everything works right it
starts with the self and then it
includes the other so let's say you took
an example of a friend who's just a
little too presumptuous right like the
kind of person you'd rather knock on
your door but who just opens the door
and comes in like that that kind of
thing and you like the person a lot and
there's a lot of resonance and you don't
want to lose the friendship and then so
so let's imagine what could happen here
it's not the only thing that can happen
but a thought experiment right so the
person may then question themselves like
is there something wrong with me like
because I don't really like this person
coming in my front door like is that
just me am I being weird about that or
another person can kind of stop and
think about that and they can take stock
of self and they can arrive at an answer
right for themselves like look that
person may conclude that you know what
people I'm as close to as this person
come in my front door you know what
that's okay right I don't you know I
don't need to set a boundary there right
that's possible Right more often what
the person concludes is no I don't
really want that like I I do actually
want this person to knock although and
that's okay
there's not something wrong with me it's
not that I'm being a jerk it's not that
I'm being a bad friend right because
what are they saying you might say oh
they're preparing for what the other
person could say no they're they're
countering what they're testing out to
themselves does that mean I'm a bad
friend no right that that kind of thing
so they they know and then they
understand and then they have and they
have the right to set the boundary right
like okay it's my house I try and be
generous but I still don't want people
coming in the door like you come to some
conclusion that setting the boundary is
okay and you're squared away with it
inside then you communicate the boundary
outward right and you said how do I want
to communicate that like saying hey man
don't come in the front door anymore
like that's not so good right now the
Friendship is really on the Rocks right
but to say to someone something like
yeah look I care about you and I trust
you and I know you feel the same way
about me but it just makes me nervous
you know people just come in the door
like do you mind like is it okay like if
you just please not knock on the door
now think about how that's been done
like it's so
accurate right to what's going on inside
the person to how the person wants to
communicate with the other then you have
the highest likelihood of Effectiveness
right and the person also in that sense
has sort of the clean conscience so to
speak that lets them take in information
back so let's say the other person
hopefully has a high generative drive
and all the good things we're talking
about could say oh you know I'm sorry I
didn't I mean I didn't mean to make you
feel uncomfortable it kind of just
automatically do that or you know I
always do that at my brother's house and
it's close by or whatever the person is
saying no worries okay everything is
fine right but let's say that person
does get mad
right now you know like whoa what's
going on in this person right because
now what you're doing is you're seeing
signs of unhealth in the other person
and it may be that whoa that's not so
healthy with the person but I like other
aspects of the friendship and that seems
like kind of a strange idiosyncrasy then
you might decide you know what I want to
keep this friendship so I'll start
locking the door
and the person has to knock or you might
think okay is this is am I seeing
something here that's about lack of
consideration right it's about
selfishness that ultimately maybe about
Envy I'm going to walk into your house
and ruin your privacy you know I'm gonna
walk in jail and make you feel anxious I
I feel entitled to do that like that's
the kind of thing that's really coming
through the lens of Envy so then you
start thinking about that and and maybe
not always of course sometimes you find
a friend who
can do the right thing sometimes you
find a friend who can't and you can
still make the Friendship work sometimes
you find a person who's not a friend
right and you see like oh that's how
everything is with this person he
realized like there's no us
there's no us right and and that's
that's how people can leave
relationships that that ultimately are
exploitive in one way or another whether
it's a friendship it's a romance so if a
person really understands there's the me
the you the magical Bridge of us and
then wait there's no magical Bridge of
us
I feel that there's a magical Bridge of
us but the other person doesn't there's
immense power of understanding and then
of appropriate self-care and
self-protection
over and over again not just during
today's episode but in the previous two
episodes it seems that
getting squared away with oneself or at
least one's own internal processes to
some degree right gaining some insight
as to where the negative or even
positive emotion within us is arising
when we're in relationship to anyone or
anything it just seems so key it's like
the foundation of it you know you know
you said you know like getting to the
maximum amount of agency and gratitude
is the goal really and that's done by
cycling back through the cupboards that
reside under structure of self and
function of self and asking questions
about oneself and and really unless we
are trained psychiatrists like you and
none of us really should be doing that
for the other person it seems with this
is really our each and all of our own
responsibility to do for ourselves but
that it serves others in so many
positive ways right right so
mentalization greases the progress of
all things good right because it is
about actual understanding feeling
States intentions but I have to first
mentalize about me before I mentalize
about you a way of putting this would be
if I'm thinking about you before I'm
thinking about me I'm on a Fool's errand
right you have to start with the self
and to try and attain Clarity of self or
to realize that you can't right like
that's it's a it's a very important
Nuance if I know that say there's trauma
in me about a certain thing and I know
that I respond in ways where sometimes
my emotions get high and I can't quite I
can't quite think through it all right
which can happen to me with with
references or or something that's
encompassing a certain kind of trauma I
want to be aware of that right so this
idea of not only being aware of what you
know about yourself but being aware that
there are things you don't know about
yourself so if I know enough to know
that a certain kind of interaction about
a certain kind of trauma really sets me
to a place where I'm not able to
mentalize like I normally would be right
I'm I'm sort of Flying Blind right then
good for me to know that because I don't
know what that's doing to me so it's the
last time to make conclusion so let's
say I'm in that state let's say I'm in
that state because of something that
just happened right and now we have some
sort of conflict right and for me to
realize like well what's going on in me
I'm bringing to this a lack of clarity
because I'm I'm really activated right
in essence the anxiety the tension in me
has been raised the negative emotion
that reflexive negative affect feeling
emotion has been raised in me and then I
realized like I don't know how it's
going to go if we interact about it now
because I can't rely on me so like hey
can we talk about this later the same
way if you recognize in the other that
person who's usually rational is all
worked up recognize that in the other
right and maybe that person doesn't
realize that they still want to interact
and you say can we let's let's revisit
this and we're like we're both kind of
calm cool and collected right so
mentalization greases the wheels of all
progress but like anything else has to
be deployed in in a way that works in
the way that works is I start with me
then I go to you and then I go to us
I'm fully on board to start with me then
to the other and then to us
model it makes total sense in fact so
much so that I'm
starting to build an image of my mind
where
first is a kind of a rule which is you
know it starts with self-understanding
and you know thoughtful structured
inquiry along the lines of the map that
was laid out in episodes one and two of
this series and that we've been alluding
to numerous times today yes and then
there's a second line or or rule that
I've got you know written on this
imaginary piece of paper in my mind
where anytime I default to thinking
about another
without first going to my own map and
exploring what's going on with me that
my own map starts to become blurry like
I'm losing access to it and it
potentially could disappear I'm just
creating this in my own mind as a way to
create a little bit of I think healthy
anxiety
to really go there first Paints the
picture yes and
you know the the purpose in having such
a you know an image in my mind that you
know access to the self and
understanding of self is potentially
drifting away is because I think for me
there's a third line in this rule rule
set that I'm imagining which is that
the less understanding we have of our
own map and internal process the more
likely I am where we all are to just
latch on to an unhealthy map another
unhealthy map yes I have to even follow
the directions of our own unhealthy map
right which leads us to someone else's
unhealthy map and then we latch onto it
like you said yeah absolutely yes you
know that's right because it's still
active even if it's blurry or if it's
obscured from my awareness and uh
drifting away if I'm trying to guide
myself with my broken Compass I run into
someone else with a broken Compass now
we're both wandering right so be aware
if the compass isn't working the way we
want it to can we go look at that can we
can we make the map healthy make the map
accurate make the map guide us towards
what we want because then we will find
other people who've worked on their own
maps that way
absolutely and you know and so often I
hear about and frankly I've experienced
you know that this feeling like oh it's
just a matter of finding somebody who is
healthy right and then things will be
much easier and much better and surely
that has to be the case and surely there
have to be instances where people you
know have a
interaction with somebody that leads to
a relationship with somebody and the
other person is much healthier and and
whatever trauma we come to the
relationship with is best supported or
better supported than it would be if we
were with somebody exploitive or who was
truly damaged you know in some way who
basically had a map that was really I
want to say screwed up but that they had
not explored they need a lot of work
they need a lot of work but I don't see
that very often I definitely see people
who at least from my outside read seem
to have healthy Maps or are doing
regular exploration of their maps and
therefore healthy who knows I don't know
what they do with their with their time
um in every domain of life but
once again we come back to this
importance of understanding what's in
those cupboards what's in those pillars
as a
not just important but critical step in
understanding and building ourselves in
positive ways and you know as I said
once or twice before in the series but
I'm going to say it again
and I'm sure again and again before we
conclude this series is that what's so
attractive about this map is that it it
sets a very clear and simple set of
ideals not necessarily simple to attain
and as you said it takes time but agency
concept and gratitude you know
empowerment humility leading up to
peace contentment and Delight all as
action States not as passive states to
just bask in and you know and and
disappear and this notion of the the
generative drive and and by now in in
this episode I'm sure people are well on
board the understanding that the
generative drive is not just about going
out and doing things it's about doing
things in service to and in a way that
supports learning knowing creating not
just of others and in the world but in
science yes I I love
I love the the map imagery because you
can almost see the map changing right as
a person I imagine the person is busying
away in the cupboards right oh there's a
lot to work on in this cupboard and
they're busy away and they're doing the
work and we can see the map changing
that path that looked like a really good
path actually goes through a swamp you
can see the swamp on the map now it
appears on the map that other path that
looked like it's a little circuitous
that's a good path right it might be a
harder path it is a little circuitous
but look where it leads right the map
becomes clear as we do the work on
ourselves yes and also the understanding
that you've laid out for us here really
helps avoid a lot of the common pitfalls
that are associated with you know sticky
language and sticky for good reason I
mean what's stickier and more
interesting for people that are
interested in themselves in relationship
than things like you know boundaries or
or labels like anxious attached or
secure attached I'm not being
disparaging of those labels but I'm
realizing those are just labels right
they don't Define Act action items and
specific lines of inquiry
to get us back into our
self-understanding over and over
and not as a full-time job right we all
have to live our lives but as a way
actually to be more leaned into life in
the outside world those labels Define
people know better than the numerical
diagnoses in the psychiatric taxonomy
book that we glorify right labels are
not understanding numbers are not
understanding they can help taxonomies
are good sometimes labels let us
categorize things but labels are not a
substitute for understanding numbers are
not a substitute for understanding if we
look at ourselves we get real
understanding and that's what makes the
difference that's what bolster's agency
gratitude all those good things clear
mentalization greasing the wills of
progress more the generative Drive
getting stronger we really can find
goodness and often do and that's why I
think everything we're talking about is
very hopeful I mean it acknowledges
there's complexity they're pitfalls
right there are all sorts of things to
it that we need to be aware of and to be
aware of but that doesn't mean that
ultimately it isn't positive that we're
not speaking to hey whatever it is
that's ailing you that thing can be
better
well I'm so grateful that you're sharing
your knowledge and experience around all
of this with us and that you've laid out
such a clear and logical
and deep
and tractable really actionable
understanding of all this that we can
engage in is tremendously powerful thank
you I so appreciate it thank you thank
you for joining me for today's
discussion about how to improve your
relationships with Dr Paul Conte I'd
also like to take a moment to remind you
that the fourth episode in the series on
Mental Health with Paul Conte will be
out next week and that links to all the
episodes can be found at hubermanlab.com
if you're learning from and or enjoying
this podcast please subscribe to our
YouTube channel that's a terrific zero
cost way to support us in addition
please subscribe to the podcast on both
Spotify and apple and on both Spotify
and apple you can leave us up to a
five-star review please also check out
the sponsors mentioned at the beginning
and throughout today's episode that's
the best way to support this podcast if
you have questions for me or comments
about the podcast or guess that you'd
like me to consider hosting on the
huberman Lab podcast please put those in
the comment section on YouTube I do read
all the comments and if you're not
already following me on social media I
am huberman lab on all platforms so
that's Instagram Twitter LinkedIn
threads and Facebook and on all those
platforms I discuss science and science
related tools some of which overlap with
the content of the huberman Lab podcast
but much of which is distinct from the
content of the huberman Lab podcast so
again it's huberman lab on all social
media channels not on today's episode
but on many previous episodes of The
huberman Lab podcast we discuss
supplements while supplements aren't
necessary for everybody many people
derive tremendous benefit from them for
things like enhancing sleep for hormone
support and for Focus if you'd like to
see the supplements discussed on the
Hebrew Lab podcast you can go to live
momentous spelled ous so it's
livemomentis.com huberman if you haven't
already subscribed to our newsletter it
is a zero cost newsletter called the
neural network newsletter and in the
neural network newsletter you get free
podcast summaries as well as tool kits
the toolkits are brief PDFs that list
off the specific science-backed
protocols for things like improving your
sleep improving Focus optimizing
dopamine deliberate cold exposure we
have a complete summary of our fitness
series again all available completely
zero cost you simply go to
hubermanlab.com go to the menu scroll
down to newsletter and provide your
email to sign up we do not share your
email with anybody thank you once again
for joining me for today's discussion
with Dr Paul conti and last but
certainly not least thank you for your
interest in science
[Music]